bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de 24h Sénat et à
l'actualité du Sénat aujourd'hui c'est
la présentation du rapport sur la loi
littorale une loi qui a je cite freiné
le bétonnage de nos côtes mais dont la
mise en œuvre bloquerait le
développement des territoires concernés
alors il faut donc l'adapter et mieux
prendre en compte le changement
climatique comme nous l'expque la
sénatrice
socialiste elle est l'un des auteurs de
ce texte au micro de s je me réjou alors
il y a peut-être des endroits où il y a
eu une mauvaise mauvaise adaptation
application de la loi je pense par
exemple à la tempête Xantia on a vu
qu'il y avait des zones vrai simplement
il y aurait pas dû avoir de construction
mais globalement tout ce qu'on a vu de
cette année dernière enfin à la fin de
l'année dernière c'est la submersion
marine c'est les euh les côtes qui
reculent c'est lié donc au changement
climatique et là c'est vraiment une
obligation aussi pour la loi littorale
de s'adapter prendre en compte ses
évolutions futures mais ce n'est pas
simple et on reste au Sénat avec la
mission d'information sur le sport
professionnel qui poursuit cet
après-midi ses auditions les
représentants des ligues de sport sont
actuellement entendus par les sénateurs
il s'inquiète du coût de construction
des des enceintes sportives parfois trop
élevé pour collecité territoriale on
écoute à ce propos le sénateur RDS de
laavon Stéphane
Mazar à chaque fois qu'on nous présente
donc ces divers projets que ce soit dans
les sports de salle ou dans les sports
en pleire on nous parle d'un modèle
économique qui repose sur le spectacle
sportif lui-même mais comme vous l'avez
dit sur également donc la capacité
d'accueillir des grands
spectacles alors à chaque fois on est un
petit peu songeur parce qu'on se dit
quand même que si tout le territoire est
maillé de grandes infrastructures qui
perd permettent donc d'accueillir des
grands concerts les grands artistes ils
se démultiplient pas ensuite est-ce que
véritablement en France il y a un
potentiel public même pour le spectacle
sportif au même titre que ce qui se
passe en Angleterre pour le football
ouou en Allemagne on sait par exemple
que dans ces pays lorsque des clubs sont
derniers du classement voir même en
Ligue 2 ou en D2 ben ils continuent à à
accueillir 25000 30000 spectateurs qu'on
y va en famille qu'on y consomme et
cetera il y a vraiment une culture du
du du du spectacle sportif et et et du
et du match qu'on a peut-être pas encore
en France tout de suite place à la
séance on va retrouver Tam tranuit en
duplexe de l'hémicycle du Sénat bonjour
Tam bonjour Delphine alors les sénateurs
poursuivent l'examen en seconde lecture
du projet de loi consommation et en
débat cet après-midi et bien il s'agit
de la résiliation des contrats
d'assurance où on est-on exactement Tam
oui bien écoutez les sénateurs ont parlé
depuis le début de l'après-mid midi
depuis 14h30 assurance il y a un sujet
effectivement qui a suscité les patients
c'est l'assurance emprunteur
c'est-à-dire l'assurance à laquelle un
client doit souscrire lorsqu'il prend un
prêt immobilier alors l'objectif de la
loi c'est ouvrir davantage cette
assurance à la concurrence pour
favoriser le consommateur et pour cela
et bien il y a une mesure phare cette
mesure et bien c'est d'instorer un délai
d'un an à partir de la signature de
l'offre de prêt 12 mois qui peuvent
permettre au clli de souscrire à une
assurance alternative une autre
assurance que celle qu'a proposé la
banque alors le thème a inspiré les
sénateurs plus d'une trentaine
d'amendements ont été déposés sur le
sujet certains voulaient prolonger le
délai d'autres voulaient encore le
raccourcir c'est finalement le délai
retenu par l'Assemblée 12 mois qui a été
également tenu par le Sénat à noter
quand la banque accepte et bien qu'il y
ait une assurance emprunteur de
substitution elle ne peut exiger aucun
prêt par exemple pour rédigé un avenant
au contrat de crédit initial et bien
c'est là l'un des apports du Sénat merci
beaucoup Tam pour toutes vos explication
alors tout de suite au direction
l'hémicycle poursuiveent la séance et on
se retrouve à partir de 19h pour 24h
Sénat le journalque de la précédente
séance a été distribué il n'y a pas
d'observation le procès-verbal est donc
adopté sous les réserves d'usage l'ordre
du jour rappelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté en 2e
lecture par l'Assemblée nationale
relatif à la consommation dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus à l'amendement numéro 309 au
sein de l'article
19è je vous rappelle que le Sénat a
décidé à la demande de la Commission
l'examen séparé de cet
amendement nous en arrivons donc à
l'article 309 la parole est à Monsieur
Cornu vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue
oui merci monsieur le président il
ressort des débats la volonté des
parlementaires d'instituer un délai
après l'acceptation de l'offre par
l'emprunteur pour que ce dernier puisse
proposer au prêteur une solution
alternative d'assurance présentant des
garanties équivalentes à cell souscrite
lors de l'acceptation de l'offre
elle prévoyait donc le cas dans lequel
l'emprunteur propose une autre assurance
après l'émission de l'offre et avant son
acceptation leur mise en œuvre se
traduira par une complexité
opérationnelle accrue avec le nouveau
délai institué par ce projet de loi
l'intérêt de couvrir cette situation
diminue fortement puisque l'emprunteur
disposera désormais d'un cadre légal
après
l'acceptation merci quel est l'avis de
la commission monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
avec les amain avec l'examen de
l'amendement 309 nous ouvrons le débat
sur le principal sujet nouveau introduit
au stade de la 2è lecture sur ce projet
de loi pourquoi cette avancée
apparaît-elle en fin de navette deux
raisons l'exlique la question a été
abordée lors des débats sur la loi de
régulation bancaire mais l'importance du
sujet justifiait une évaluation
préalable elle a été confi à
l'Inspection des Finances qui a publié
son rapport en novembre dernier le
problème a été posé en lo banire mais la
solution se rattache à un texte de la
consommation car il s'agit liberté de
choix de l'assurer et le présent projet
comporte d'ors et déjà des avancées
majeures pour faciliter le changement
d'assurance automobile habitation
assurance d affinitaire comme celles qui
sont proposées aux acheteurs de
téléphonees portabl la possibilité de
choix doit favoriser la concurrence et
nous l'espérons la baisse des primes
j'en viens à la signification globale de
la position prise par la commission
d'abord sur le principe essentiel d'un
délai de substitution limité à 12 mois
pour limiter la démutualisation tout en
exerçant une pression concurrentielle
sur le niveau élevé des commissions le
bon sens immédiat plaidit en faveur de
l'extension pure et simple de la liberté
de choix illimitée au domaine de
l'assuranceur et pourtant les quelques
300 pages du rapport de l'Inspection des
finances comporte un message de prudence
dans ce domaine pourquoi parce que notre
modèle français de l'assurance
emprunteur qui est une singularité dans
les pays développés comporte une
dimension cachée qui se résume au
concept de
mutualisation concrètement la
mutualisation se traduit par le fait
qu'à qu'à 56 ans l'imprunteur peut
assurer le remboursement de son prêt
contre le risque de décès en payant une
prime seulement deux ou trois fois plus
élevée qu'à 26 ans tel était tel était
encore le cas il y a plusieurs années et
je note qu'un amendement de Madame Marie
Noel lman exprime le souhait d'imposer
une égalité des primes quel que soit
l'âge et la prof profession cependant
les choses évoluent vite et cette
mutualisation a d'or et déjà un peu
décliné au profit de la vérité des prix
ou plus exactement de la vérité des
primes calculé en fonction de
l'espérance de vie certains assureurs
alternatifs proposent ainsi depuis
quelques années des tarifs très
intéressants aux jeunes coupes mais 7 à
fois plus élevés pour les plus pour pour
les 56 ans il faut donc comme bien
souvent dans les affaires publiques
naviguer entre deux eau la liberté de
choix totale pendant toute la vie du
prêt c'est ce que souhaitent les
organisations de consommateurs s'ignorer
selon l'inspection des Finances la fin
de la mutualisation or les sondages
montrent que citoyens ils sont attaché
et
peu et peu comme pour notre mod un peu
comme excusez-moi un peu comme pour
notre modèle
social votre commission a donc estimé
qu'il fallait préserver la mutualisation
ou plus exactement ne pas trop accélérer
le processus en cours de démutualisation
pour autant je me tourne vers notre
collègue Marie Noë linman la Commission
estime périlleuse l'idée de décréter
l'égalité des primes pour tous car cela
reviendit d'abord à bouleverser la
logique de l'assurance et ensuite en
pratique à exclure les personnes âgées
de l'accès au crédit immobilier ce sera
en notre sens la conséquence la plus
tragique et je le rappelle que partout
dans le monde un banquier est en droit
de refuser un prêt en même temps la
Commission a désapprouvé les amendements
qui tendent à geler la situation
actuelle ou à limiter à 3 4 ou 6 mois le
droit de substitution le statut co ne
nous paraît pas souhaitable pour une
raison majeur qui renvoie la deuxième
caractéristique fondamentale l'assurance
empointeur je veux parler du niveau
élevé des commissions réservées par les
assureurs aux banques il y a là une
marge de manœuvre pour donner une
impulsion à la concurrence et par suite
selon selon toute vraisemblance à la
baisse se dé primimes en pensant aux
banquiers assureurs qui ont pu
solliciter les uns et les autres
j'apporterai un petit bémol à cette
remarque sur le niveau élevé des primes
d'assurance emprunteur respectons aussi
l'arithmétique les taux d'intérêt et a
atteint un plancher historique il n'est
pas étonnant que l'assurance hteur
représente une proportion importante du
coût du crédit bref entre immobilis et
la liberté de choix illimitée la
Commission a choisi une liberté de
substitution pendant les 12 mois qui
suivent la signature du contrat de prêt
cela soulève des objections à la fois
des partisans du statuco et des
partisans de la liberté totale mais au
total les diverses positions exprimées
dans la liace d'amendements que nous
allons examiner trace un nuage de point
dont la tendance moyenne correspond au
texte adopté par la commission 12 mois
de liberté de
substitution les amendements que nous
allons examiner soulèvent par ailleurs
la question des modalités de ce
changement tout d'abord plusieurs
amendements concernent les frais de
substitution et comme vous le savez le
diable est dans les détails le texte
adopté par la commission par principe
les intérêts en matière d'assurance et
je vous soumets un amendement pour qui
interdit également les frais induits par
la modification du contrat de PR je
demanderai le rallimement des
amendements ayant le même objet à la
rédaction de la commission je vous
salement un amendement qui répond au
préoccupations parfaitement fondées des
asstion de consommateurs et de nos
collègues il s'agit de sanctionner le
banquier qui manquerait à son obligation
d'accepter la substitution du contrat
d'assurance en créant une amende de 3000
€. là aussi je sollicite le ralliment
des auteurs d'amendement similaires à la
rédaction proposée par votre commission
par ailleurs de façon plus technique
plusieurs amendements soulèvent la
question de la substitution après le
délis dégal de 12 mois rien n'empêche
dans le texte adopté par la commission
la banque et son client de signer un
contrat qui prévoit une telle
possibilité de substitution c'est la
liberté contractuelle l'idée soutenue
par certains de nos collègues est
d'encadrer les clauses de ce contrat à
mon avis cela conduit à compliquer la
rédaction de la loi sans pour autant
changer son résultat pratique puisque le
banquier pourra ne pas proposer des
possibilités de substitution ou bien
faire une proposition à sortie de frais
de dossier où je l'espère sans frais en
hier soir notre collègue Marie Noë diman
a soulevé l'intérêt ente question de la
conformité à la Constitution de ce droit
de substitution certains ont en effet
tenté d'assimiler la substitution et la
rétractation en soulignant que le droit
en vigueur ne donne aucun exemple de
délai de rétractation atteignant 12 mois
toutefois je pense sincèrement qu'un
changement d'assurance emprunteur
s'apparente pas non pas à une
rétractation mais bien à une résiliation
sans quoi par le même raisonnement on en
viendrait à remettre en cause le droit
de changer d'abonnement téléphonique ou
de l'assurance habitation au total je le
redis à travers ces quelques amendements
se dégage si on si on en fait la moyenne
une ligne directrice que nous avons
suivie je vous remercie donc je tâcherai
à sur mes avis de mainenir à à cette
ligne moyenne voilà merci avez du
gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président je
vais euh comme le le rapporteur si vous
le voulez bien donner parce que je n'ai
pas eu l'occasion de faire hier soir la
position du du gouvernement sur cette
question de l'assurance emprunteur et
vous dire ce que sera notre attitude à
l'égard des des différents amendements
qui ont été déposés ce qui permettra de
de de rétrécir peut-être le temps
consacré au débat sur sur chaque
amendement mais je voulais donc vous
donner vous faire partager les les
quelques
mots suivants sur cet article 19 optiè
c'est en effet une réforme très
importante qui est notamment très
attendue par un bon nombre de de ceux
qui aujourd'hui souscrivent à un emprint
immobilier qui souhaitent que évidemment
le capital qui le rembourse et les taux
d'intérêt qui soient pratiqué soitent
les plus bas mais qui sont aussi
attentifs au montant des taux pratiqués
en matière d'assurance emprunteur parce
que nous avons eu l'occasion de le dire
à plusieurs reprises l'assurance
emprinteur ça peut représenter jusqu'à
1/3 du coût du crédit et qu'il est assez
légitime que celles et ceux qui
empruntent puissent bénéficier des
conditions de fluidité du marché des
conditions de concurrence pour faire le
cas échéant baisser les prix et avoir
moins à rembourser qui ce qui dans une
période de pouvoir d'achat où le pouvoir
d'achat est tendu pour bon nombre de
ménag est une évidemment un gain tout à
fait important comme vous savez le
gouvernement défend depuis plus d'un an
des mesures qui visent à rembourser au
bénéfice des consommateurs donc la
concurrence sur le marché de l'assurance
emprunteur la loi de séparation et de
régulation des activités bancaires
comporte ainsi des mesures de
transparence avec pour commencer la
création du taux annuel effectif de
l'assurance le taea qui permet au
consommateur de bien connaître le coût
de son assurance emprteur c'est déjà en
soit un élément de transparence un
élément de progrès puisqu'on sait
exactement combien va vous coûter
l'assurance emprunteur cette loi
comprend également des mesures qui
visent à assurer la pleine effectivité
du dispositif qui avait été mis en place
sous la précédente majorité dans le
cadre de la loi la garde et qui
constituait la première ouverture à la
concurrence de ce marché de l'assurance
en emprunteur don il est vite apparu
qu'il était nécessaire de le
déverrouiller encore davantage lors des
débats sur la loi bancaire puis à
nouveau en première lecture du projet de
loi consommation qui revient aujourd'hui
en 2è lecture il y a eu une demande
quasi unanime des deux assemblées mais
aussi surtous les les banques qu'il soit
de gauche du centre ou ou de droite de
faire en sorte pour que le gouvernement
aille plus loin de nombreux amendements
avaient ainsi été déposés et défendus
pour demander que la loi permette
d'ouvrir une capacité de de changer
d'assurance plus seulement avant la
signature du prêt mais au-delà et à tout
moment sans limite de durée Pierre
Moscovici et moi-même avions à l'époque
souligné les risques que comporte une
telle réforme il n'y a pas que des
avantages à ouvrir à certain de marché à
la concurrence notamment dans le domaine
de la de l'assurance puisque il y avait
notamment un risque de démutuellisation
qui était lié à l'ouverture de ce marché
qu'il était nécessaire pour les pouvoirs
publics de tenir compte de ce risque le
risque de mutualisation qui aurait pu
conduire à une très forte segmentation
de l'offre évidemment au détriment de
qui toujours les mêmes publics les
population au profil de risque les plus
élevés c'est-à-dire les emprunteurs les
plus âgés ou connaissant un risque
aggravé de santé je me permets ce
rappelle pour bien souligner que c'est
le gouvernement le premier qui a
souligné ce risque et sur ce point il
n'a pas changé ni de discours ni de
position nous voulons que le coût de
l'assurance emprunteur baisse mais sans
que ce soit là soit pardon excusez-moi
au prix d'une démutu
isation qui qui amène de facto à ce que
les populations les plus exposées
notamment les les personnes âgés payent
elle le prix de cette ouverture à la
concurrence dès lors qu'elle voudrait
emprunter pierre moscovicier et moi-même
nousous sommes donc engagés à aller plus
loin tout en rappelant que nous le
ferions quand nous assurons que la
réforme que nous porterions éviterait
donc d'aller trop loin c'est le sens de
ce que je viens de vous dire pour nous
aider dans nos travaux nous avons donc
demandé à l'IGF euh de l'Inspection
générale des finances de nous faire un
rapport sur ce sujet sa principale
conclusion est de souligner à quel point
aujourd'hui la concurrence ne joue pas
assez sur le marché de l'assurance
emprunteur ce qui se traduit notamment
par des marges trop élevées il fallait
donc agir faire des propositions
permettant véritablement à la
concurrence de jouer dans l'intérêt des
consommateurs pour cela l'IGF proposait
d'ouvrir une fenêtre de 3 mois à compter
de la signature du prêt pendant laquelle
l'emprunteur gardait la faculté de
substituer son assurance par une autre
selon le même mécanisme que celui
proposé et mis en place par la loi la
garde le gouvernement a repris cette
idée mais en faisant le choix d'une
fenêtre non pas de 3 mois mais de 12
mois pourquoi avons-nous fait ce choix
tout simplement tout simplement parce
que nos consultations à la fois auprès
des acteurs de marché mais aussi auprès
des associations de consommateurs ont
montrer que le délai de 3 mois était
trop court pour être véritablement
efficace la en réalité c'est quoi c'est
que lorsque vous achetez un logement à
crédit vous avez de nombreuses
préoccupations en tête vous devez
trouver le logement à acquérir puis
trouver une banque qui vous prête de
quoi l'acheter vous devez organiser la
signature d'un compromis de vente puis
d'une vente chez un notaire vous devez
en même temps organiser votre
déménagement le cas échéant
l'inscription de vos enfants à l'école
vous devez satisfaire à à plusieurs
procédures administratives et puis
au-delà du déménagement très souvent
vous devez faire aussi des travaux bref
dans la période qui suit qui la
signature d'un prêt c'est dans cette
période d'acquisition d'unallogement
honnêtement euh bon nombre de nos
compatriotes sont mobilisés concentrés
sur bien d'autrre chose que le fait de
regarder ce que va être véritablement le
coût lié à l'assurance emprunteur et
l'impact pour eux sur leur pouvoir
d'achat de de cette assurance emprunteur
et donc assez peu mobilisé à faire jouer
la concurrence dans ce domaine là c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons voulu
que cette fenêtre de 3 mois que nous
jugions trop courte pour substituer à
l'assurance initiale une nouvelle
assurance et la donc la remplacer
l'étendre dans le temps de façon à ce
que nos compatriotes consommateur puisse
avoir un délai suffisant 12 mois pour
être en capacité bien de faire jouer la
concurrence de comparer de solliciter
des offres de faire avec les nouveaux
acteurs ceux qui vont quand même entrer
en force dans le champ de l'assurance
emprunteur faire en sorte de voir si
l'assurance emprunteur qu'ils ont
souscrit de leur banque directement
présentent les mêmes avant avantage que
celle qu'on leur propose à l'extérieur à
garantie équivalente je le répète en
tout cas ils feront jouer pendant 12
mois c'est qui le temps utile cette
concurrence pourquoi en sens inverse ne
pas aller au-delà de ce délai de 12 mois
tout simplement parce que comme je l'ai
dit le gouvernement n'a pas varié ni
Pierre Moscovici ni moi-même depuis le
début sur ce sujet nous ne voulons pas
prendre le risque d'aller trop loin 12
mois est de ce point de vue une période
raisonnable puisque le profil de risque
l'emprunteur du point de vue de l'âge en
particulier ne varie pas suffisamment
sur 12 mois pour que cela puisse fonder
une segmentation suppplémentaire madame
linman hier soir en toute fin de nos
débats entre minuit écart et et et
minuit 25 vous m'aviez interrogé hier
pour savoir si cette période de 12 mois
n'était pas trop longue et
disproportionné au risque d'être
inconstitutionnel je voudrais vous
rassurer sur ce point vous avez fait un
parallèle qui a été évoqué par par le
rapporteur à l'instant avec la situation
prévalent en matière d'assurance vie
dans laquelle il existe un droit de
renonciation de 30 jours or il s'agit là
de deux situations très différentes et
d'un dernier mot je voudrais euh vous
apporter les les précisions suivantes ce
que le gouvernement introduit dans cet
article c'est un droit de résiliation
accompagné d'une obligation
d'acceptation de la substitution par qui
le prêteur si les garanties offertes par
le contrat sont équivalentes et non
comme dans le cas de l'assurance vie un
droit de renonciation l'exercice d'un
droit de résiliation met fin au contrat
dans ce cas notamment les primes
correspondantes à la période pendant
laquelle l'assureur a couvert le risque
lui son l'exercice d'un droit de
renonciation quant à lui a pour effet de
ramener les cocontractant dans l'état
antérieur à la signature du contrat
entre autres conséquences les primes
doivent être dans ce cas remboursé à
l'assuré ce que nous mettons en place
procède bien du point de vue du contrat
d'assurance d'un droit de résiliation et
non d'un droit de renon ronciation un
droit de renonciation de 12 mois aurait
été nous en convenons disproportionné
mais ce n'est pas ce que nous proposons
nous proposons nous de tenir compte de
cet écueil là pour justement éviter
l'inconstitutionnalité de cette période
de 12 mois je vous rappelle enfin qu'il
existe pour les contrats à Tacite
recondu un droit de résiliation annuelle
et que cette loi introduit pour les
assurances auto MRH un droit de
résoliation à tout moment cette fois-ci
à compté de la première année de
souscription pour ces assurances comme
pour l'assurance emprunteur je ne
considère pas que l'introduction de
droit de résiliation pose de problèmes
constitutionnels voilà je termine mon
propos un peu long pardon mais je
voulais donner sur ce point ce qui était
la position du gouvernement avant
d'entrer dans le débat des des 30
amendements pour lequels vous me
pardonnerez mais du coup j'iraai
probablement parfois plus vite mais le
gouvernement sera donc défavorable à
tous les amendements qui dans un sens le
rétrécissement ou
lecissement ou dans un autre
l'allongement proposerai de revenir sur
la durée de 12 mois qui est aujourd'hui
dans le texte de même je serai
défavorable aux amendements qui
reviennent sur l'ambition de la réforme
à l'inverse je serai favorable à ce
déposer par le rapporteur qui me semble
d'ailleurs répondre à des soujets
soulevés par plusieurs autres d'entre
vous je vous remercie merci Monsieur le
Ministre est-ce qu'il y a des
explications de vote
monsieur monsieur hon
oui monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur j'ai entendu avec intérêt
d'ailleurs vos
explications je voudrais peut-être y
apporter un un petit complément vous
avez parlé je crois à juste raison de la
nécessité de garder une mutualisation
sur la couverture du risque d'assurance
emprunteur puisque finalement
aujourd'hui dans notre
système concurrentiel mais pas autant
que les consommateurs le souhaiteraient
mais aussi j'ai bien entendu ce que vous
av dit monsieur le ministre il faut que
ces mêmes consommateurs comprennent que
parfois c'est aussi pour une protection
je m'explique vous avez grosso modo
aujourd'hui deux dispositifs de
protection soit vous avez ce qu'on
appelle l'assurance emprunteur par un
contrat groupe une mutualisation
générale quelque part sans tranche d'âge
vous êtes dans une situation de
personnes d'âge on va dire actif et en
général on vous pose entre 3 et 5
questions relativement simple voire
parfois aucune question
donc quand vous n'avez aucune question
la contrepartie c'est que vous avez
adhéré quoi qu'il vous arrive ensuite
puisque finalement dans
l'assuranceinteur la couverture c'est
quoi c'est le
risque et sur le risque santé c'est
notamment l'arrêt de travail ou le décès
ce qui veut dire quand vous n'avez
aucune question que tous les risques
médicaux sont couverts quoi qu'il arrive
vous avez donc dans ce caslà une mise en
comment diraisje en action automatique
et je crois que c'est dans l'absolu le
mieux puisque on ne fait pas enfin on ne
tient pas compte ou très peu ça dépend
de l'état de santé et puis vous avez
dans le jeu de la concurrence qui s'est
mis en place c'est quoi bah globalement
c'est deux
trois je dirais moyens c'est un l'âge de
l'emprunteur al évidemment à la fois par
l'état de santé on sait que en moyenne
on est en meilleure santé à 18 20 ou 25
ans statistiquement que à 55 qu'on a
donc de la même manière une plus grande
espérance de vie donc moins de risque de
décès et ça permet aux assureurs de
faire une mutualisation non pas sur une
période de 35 ou 40 années mais par
tranche d'âge et en général d'ailleurs
quelque part par risque
professionnel c'est donc une
mutualisation que je vais appeler
catégorielle mais ça permet
effectivement à certains d'entre nous de
pouvoir bénéficier de conditions plus
avantageuses puisque vous avez bien
compris que si on a trois tranches d'âge
mettons les 18 35 ans 35 50 et plus de
50 là c'est plus favorable aux jeunes
que un âge moyen qui se situe entre 45
et 50 ans la paliss en aurait dit autant
simplement il y a je pense on ne répond
pas à toutes les questions et monsieur
le ministre je veux là vous vous en
parler sur la question des 12 mois des 6
mois des 3 mois de toute façon on ne
trouvera pas de système parfait il
serait bon néanmoins de pouvoir
permettre je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est la résiliation la résiliation il
faut savoir que pour l'assurer
elle a une conséquence c'est qu'il
repart à zéro avec un nouveau
questionnaire qui peut être un
questionnaire ouvert ou en tous les cas
un questionnaire de santé ce qui veut
dire puce que le fait générateur de la
couverture de l'assurance emprunteur
c'est l'état de santé lorsque survient
le risque et le risque c'est que parfois
vous avez des comment dirais-je des des
assurés qui considèent que que de
prendre des médicaments et cetera ça
voilà tout va bien mais il se considère
pas comme étant soigné bah si quand on
prend un médicament forcément on est
soigné mais même dans les réponses on
arrive parfois sur cette incongrué et
deuxième élément qui à mon avis n'est
pas pris en en compte dans les deux
interventions que j'ai entendu c'est le
changement de situation il faudrait au
moins professionnel salarié vous décidez
à 35 40 ans de vous installer à votre
compte d'abord vous dez en général ça
n'est pas fait vous devez théoriquement
informer l'organisme prêteur et
l'assureur du changement de
situation c'est important et en général
ça n'est pas fait donc il faut
certainement imaginer un dispositif pour
informer et avoir dans ce cas là au
moins la possibilité y compris auprès du
même organisme de pouvoir souscrire je
dirais dans les mêmes conditions que
celles qui ont été souscrite au départ
puisque le fait générateur c'est pas
votre état de santé c'est votre
changement de situation professionnelle
vous étiez cadres vous devenez
profession libérale vous étiez euh
indépendant vous devenez salariés le
fait générateur de l'assurance qui est
le montant de l'emprunt et le risque lié
à votre état de santé n'a rien à voir
avec le changement de situation
professionnel donc je veux attirer votre
attention sur cet aspect puisque dans ce
cas le dispositif dont on parle
aujourd'hui ne répond aucunement à ces
cas-là ce qui veut dire et j'en
terminerai par là que la logique c'est
d'avoir finalement peut-être un cadre
juridique d'action avec les organismes
prêteurs pour essayer de trouver des
réponses pratique pragmatique concrète
qui ne laent les intérêts de personne et
qui respectent quelque part l'engagement
initial parce que vous l'avez compr vous
l'avez compris pardon
euh aucune aucun paramètre lié à la mise
en œuvre de la souscription du risque
n'est prise en compte au départ voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire également
puisque je crois que un des objectifs
vous l'avez dit c'est de d'améliorer on
va dire les conditions de souscription
mais c'est aussi de protéger et les
organismes prêteurs et les assurer
lorsqu'ils souscrivent une garantie
d'emprunt quel que soit l'objet et le
motif pour lequel ils souscrivent cette
garantie
rocassia merci monsieur le Président
j'avais prévu une intervention mais
comme monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre et Monsieur Husson sont
intervenus je vais essayer d'être
plus résumé un peu plus cohérente enfin
cohérente par rapport à ce qui s'est dit
euh je m'exprime à titre personnel et
pas du tout au nom du groupe UMP pour
moi c'est une réforme importante
j'apprécie effectivement que lors de la
première lecture vous nous aviez
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre repoussé à la deuxème lecture
les amendements sur l'assurance
emprunteur et
qu'effectivement hasard bien calculé
peut-être mais en tout cas le rapport de
l'IGS est sorti et les amendements et et
un certain nombre de dispositions sur
l'assurance emprunteur ont été intégrées
dans ce projet de loi pour moi
effectivement par rapport à tout ce qui
est proposé dans ce projet de texte
consommation pour le pouvoir d'achat là
il y a un véritable gain de pouvoir
d'achat et non pas de 300 € tous les
300ou 4 ans pour des lunettes mais de
milliers d'euros pendant 15 ou pendant
20 ans pour ma part j'apprécie toutes
les avancées je comprends parfaitement
les hésitations de monsieur le
rapporteur entre sur les délais entre
les
raccourcir les allonger ce que j'en sais
je n'ai pas d'expérience récente en
matière personnelle de prês puisque
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur le
ministre en disant la mutualisation
c'est pour les personnes âgées les quand
on a plus de 60 ans on fait partie des
personnes âgées pour avoir un prêt je
peux vous dire que c'est déjà beaucoup
plus difficile après l'assurance
emprinteur on verra comment ça se passe
mais il faut déjà pouvoir avoir des
offres de prêt par contre ici au Sénat
nous avons beaucoup de collaborateurs
qui sont jeunes qui passent ou qui
viennent de passer ou qui sont en train
de passer par cette offre de par ces
offres de prêt immobiliers et de
multiples exemples ici du parcours du
combattant que c'est actuellement pour
souscrire ces offres de prêt donc
j'espère effectivement que les
dispositions qui sont introduites vont
enfin permettre de les c'est un
véritable délai de réflexion parce que
ce qu'il se passe actuellement c'est
qu'entre le moment où on remet l'offre
de prêt le moment où la la personne les
personnes ont accepté le prêt et
l'assurance il n'y a pas de délai là
vous permettez effectivement vous
introduisez un délai de 1 an et bien ce
délai de 1 an comme vous l'avez dit
Monsieur le Ministre entre les
déménagement le fait que quelquefois
c'est 6 mois après que l'on peut
vraiment entrer dans l'appartement ou
dans la maison va permettre de réfléchir
et de faire des vraies
comparaisons et le seul regret je pense
que pourront avoir certains sera par
rapport à la date d'application mais la
date d'application je l'ai bien compris
puisque moi aussi dans des amendements
j'ai hésité entre sur ce délai de 1 an
de pouvoir se dire à partir de quand
est-ce que c'est la publication de la
loi est-ce que
c'est parce que tous ceux qui vont
signer après il y a 15 jours ou autrees
et qui vont voir la loi ou qui vont la
voir appli
et leur offre de presse et la veille
vont se trouver quand même très frustré
et frustré sur le fonctionnement et
frustré sur les milliers de d'euros que
ça concerne tous les ans donc là
j'espère qu'en matière d'offre de près
les choses vont pouvoir
s'améliorer je pense aussi que les
assurances emprunteurs qui existent à l'
Actel pourront être effectivement
comparés parce que ce qui se passe
jusqu'à présent c'est que la banque
fournissait une offre enemprunteur mais
avec des données tellement floues qu'il
était impossible trouver une offre
comparable ou lorsque l'on apportait
cette offre comparable et bien la banque
pouvait vous dire non ce n'est pas une
offre comparable j'en avais parler lors
de la première lecture enfin vous avez
évoqué la capacité pour chaque
souscripteur de pouvoir connaître le
coût exact je crains simplement qu'à
partir du moment où cette information
soit bien précise ça fasse très peur
quand ils vont voir les les milliers
d'euros dépenser pendant 15 ans 20 ans
ou 25 ans pour le pour simplement une
offre de prês pour des offres
d'assurance pour les offres d'assurance
excusez-moi qui parfois ne couvrent pas
vraiment tous les risques nécessaires
donc pour ma part je me réjoui de des
dispositions qui sont apportées j'ai
essayé d'apporter quelqu quelques
amendements d'amélioration très concret
sur lesquels je me fais pas beaucoup
d'illusion et vous avez évoqué aussi
Monsieur le Ministre la capacité de
résiliation dans la loi la garde
rienintér disait la capacité de
résiliation et je veux saluer les
quelques banques je crois qu'il y en a
que deux en France qui jusqu'à présent
considérez bien que c'était des des
contrats tacite reconduction et qui
permettait cette résiliation j'ose
souhaiter que cette pratique grâce à
cette osition pourront se
développer merci est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres explications de vote je n'en
vois pas je vais donc mettre au voix cet
amendement qui a reçu la demande de
retrait du rapporteur et l'avis
défavorable du gouvernement quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté nous
arrivons à l'amendement 89 rectifié
qu'il défend
mon oui cet amendement donc qui vise à
préciser les garanties auxquelles
l'interdiction de modifier la
tarification pourra
s'appliquer simplement pour rappeler que
les garanties chômage ont subi dans les
années 9 un certain nombre de ce qu'on
appelle retarification du fait de la
dérive du
risque cette mesure d'ailleurs avait été
proposé à l'initiative du contrôle
prudentiel justement pour parvenir
quelque part à un équilibre des des
contrats enfin un équilibre financier
c'est pourquoi interdire toute
possibilité de modification de la
tarification sur les garanties autres
que Cell couvrant les gros risques de
décès invalidité ou incapacité aura pour
conséquence il faut en avoir conscience
que les assureurs ne proposeront plus
les garanties perte d'emploi et que ce
ça pourra être au détriment des
consommateur j'entends bien que garantir
le risque perte d'emploi d'abord il y a
deux catégories de français sur le
comment dirais-je le risque garantie
perte d'emploi et en plus il est
difficile de pouvoir mutualiser en cette
matière qui est pour le moins mouvante
quelle que soit la progression ou la
régression des courbes mais je tiens
aujourd'hui à attirer notre attention
collégiale et collective sur cet
aspect
merci avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur conément ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure
défavorable gouvernement même avis merci
pas d'explication de vote je mets donc
au voit l'amendement 89 rectifié quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire il n'est pas
adopté nous arrivons à une série de 11
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune en commençant par le
68 qui le défend madame
l je ne ser pas très long puisque de
fait le débat a déjà eu lieu il s'agit
de la du délai accordé aux emprunteurs
pour pouvoir en cause l'assurance après
la contraction euh la après le l'octroi
du prêt alors moi je pladais pour les 6
mois d'abord je crois que monsieur le
rapporteur a parfaitement compris ma
philosophie qui vise enfin je crois
notre philosophie collective qui vise à
garantir à la fois de la concurrence
mais une concurrence régulée qui
garantisse la mutualis le maintien la
mutualisation et donc la question qui
est posée c'est est-ce que le délai le
donc bravo d'abord au gouvernement
d'avoir tenu sa parole lors de la loi
bancaire nous disant que ce sujet allait
être traité puis en première lecture
nous annonçant des solutions pour la
deuxième lecture et je dois dire que les
avancé sont réelles maintenant il y a un
vrai débat sur quel est le bon délai
tout le monde Je je partage l'idée qu'
faut que ce délai soit limité parce que
l'illimité ne tiendrait pas dans la
démutualisation maintenant est-ce qu'il
faut 4 mois 6 mois 1 an on peut
considérer que a priori le 1 an une
certaine légitimité pour vu du côté de
l'usager pourquoi pas ma crainte est la
suivante elle est d'abord sur le sur la
durée qui est donnée dans dans le
l'action concrète et ensuite je
reviendrai sur la question
constitutionnelle sur la question
concrète la crainte c'est qu'on favorise
le démarchage or on est vous savez c'est
très facile quand les gens sont dans la
première année où ils remboursent leurs
prêt ils sont en général un peu serrés
finan ement et ce que je crains c'est
qu'il un démarchage un peu forcé d'un
certain nombre d'assureurs pas forcément
ceux auquel on pense le plus
naturellement possible les mutualistes
ou autres mais je pense à des assureurs
moins bienveillants qui vont essayer de
de rentrer sur ce marché qui est quand
même un marché qui a une certaine
rentabilité et la crainte qu'on a c'est
que ce démarchage forcé mal éclairé du
côté de de du consommateur puisse
pousser à une certaine accélération de
la démutu tion c'est d'ailleurs la
crainte qu'on un certain nombre
d'associations qui vous ont peut-être
écrit notamment toutes les associations
qui ont des des maladies chroniques bon
moi je pars du principe que sur ce point
si la vigilance de l'État et la
puissance publique nous permet d'évaluer
si la démutualisation s'accélère ou si
elle elle se maintient correctement on
on pourra revoir en fonction si je puis
dire du réel de de cela mais j'attire la
vigilance sur la nécessité de suivre
l'effectivité de la de la mutualisation
puis après il y a la question
constitutionnelle alors c'est vrai que
mon argumentaire a été fondé sur la
rétractation et que le gouvernement nous
dit que c'est une résiliation en cela je
peux comprendre le mécanisme simplement
il me semble que résiliation comme
rétractation le Conseil constitutionnel
quand il s'agit de modifier un contrat
regarde la légitimité des conditions de
la modification de ce contrat au titre
titre de deux points de vue l'intérêt
général et la proportion à l'objectif
poursuivi alors l'intérêt général on
peut dire chaque fois de la concurrence
et de inérêt général sauf que là il a
été prouvé que quand on mutualise
certains en profitent et d'autres n'en
profitent pas donc l'intérêt général
n'est pas collectivement réparti donc on
peut s'interroger sur le fait que le
Conseil constitutionnel considéra qu'à
ce point l'intérêt général deuxièmement
c'est la proportionnalité c'est là que
la durée intervient et dans la
proportionalité c'est aussi lié à
l'intérêt général et c'est ça peut
paraître au regard des capacités de
démarchage forcé à paraître un peu long
bon moi personnellement n'étant pas une
spécialiste du de la Constitution dans
le détail je voulais attirer l'avis du
gouvernement il me dit que c'est
constitutionnel je le crois j'espère
qu'il ne se trompe pas et à partir de ce
moment-là je retire mon mon amendement
merci ma chère collègue amendement 308
qu' le défend monsieur
Cornu oui j'ai écouté les propos du
rapporteur et du ministre donc je me
fais pas trop d'illusion sur cet
amendement mais j'avoue ne pas être
insensible au propos que vient de tenir
madame linman parce queeectivement on
dit 12 mois on dit 6 mois on dit 4 mois
moi je propose 3 mois avec Madame Lamur
mais le problème c'est que si je propose
3 mois c'est parce que je m'appuie sur
le rapport assurance emprunteur de l'IGF
et qui préconise justement d'autoriser
l'assuré à résilier son contrat
d'assurance dans les 3 mois de la
souscription pour y substituer un autre
contrat présentant des garanties
équivalentes alors en fait en
écoutant toutes les raisons évoqué et
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre vous
avez évoqué certaines raisons qui
peuvent être valables mais à la limite
bon moi je propose 3 mois mais à la
limite ce qui me paraît essentiel parce
qu'on narrive pas à bien à bien saisir
la durée euh pourquoi 12 mois pourquoi 3
mois pourquoi 4 mois je pense que sur
les durées parce que une fois que c'est
figé dans la loi si vous rendez compte
que 12 mois pour les raisons que madame
linman a invoqué tout à l'heure que en
fait il y a des des autres assureurs qui
vont démarcher et cetera si on
s'aperçoit que 12 mois finalement c'est
trop long est-ce que ça serait pas mieux
sur un truc comme ça de durée est-ce que
ce serait pas mieux de le faire par
décret parce que là ça va êre figé dans
la loi si vous vous apercevez monsieur
le ministre que finalement les 12 mois
c'est trop long et que finalement
peut-être que c'est 6 mois qu'il fallait
faire au moins un décret vous allez
pouvoir changer sans repasser par la loi
et je trouve que ça donnera une certaine
souplesse parce que finalement ni les
uns ni les autres sont sûrs de la durée
moi je m'appuie sur l'IGF mais est-ce
que c'est finalement la l'IGF qui doit
primer est-ce que c'est vous qui avez
raison sur 12 mois est-ce que c'est
madame qui a raison raison sur 6 mois
est-ce que c'est Monsieur mard qui a
raison sur 4 mois est-ce que quelqu'un
le sait exactement et par décret ça
serait peut-être plus simple de le
changer voilà la proposition que je peux
vous faire même si j'ai à défendre
l'amendement que j'avais présenté avec
Madame Lamur pour 3
mois merci amendement 56 rectifié qui le
défend monsieur
Fortassin mes chers collègues cet
amendement visa réduire la période
durant laquelle l'assurée peut se
substituer librement son contrat
d'assurance emprunte le rapport de
l'Inspection générale des finances de
novembre 2013 sur l'assurance emprunteur
préconisé de fixer à 3 mois suivant la
souscription du contrat la période
durant laquelle l'assuré peut renégocier
son contrat d'assurance emprunteur comme
cela a d'ailleurs été dit or l'article
19 du projet de zoin modifié en 2e
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale permet à
à la ur de se substituer à son contrat
d'assurance emprunteur un autre contrat
présentant un niveau de garantie
équivalent sans que le prêteur ne puisse
y opposer modifier le taux ou les
conditions d'octroit du crédit ni exiger
le paiement de fait supplémentairire
pendant une durée Dean après la
signature de l'offre de si nous sommes
favorables à l'esprit de cet article qui
vise à renforcer la concurrence en
matière d'assurance emprunteur afin de
favoriser le pouvoir d'achat de et la
liberté de choix des consommateurs nous
nous interrogeons sur la durée du délai
de substitution en effet un délai Dean
favoriserait sans doute le choix par les
assureurs de clients en dossier les
moins risqués la concurrence jouerait
essentiellement sur ce type de contrat
dont les primes seraient fortement
diminuéses pour attirer ses clients
favorisé au détriment des assurés
considérés comme présentant plus de
risque et c'est le cas des personnes
malades ou en situation de précarité
c'est donc pour limiter le risque de
démutualisation des personnes en
situation de fragilité que nous
souhaitons réduire le délai légal de
substitution d'un contrat d'assurance
emprunteur tel est l'objet de cet
amendement merci deux amendements
identiques dont le 216 Monsieur Le
Cam c'est le président monsur ministre
chers collègues par cet amendement nous
vous proposons de consolider le
dispositif de l'article 19 au du projet
de loi qui ouvre la possibilité pour le
seul emprunteur de substituer un autre
contrat d'assurance présentant un niveau
de garantie équivalent jusqu'à 12 mois
après la signature de l'offre de prêt
nous proposons d'étendre donc au-delà
des 12 mois la faculté substitution de
l'assurance emprunteur ainsi comme le
précise des associations de
consommateurs et notamment l'UFC Que
Choisir qui a travaillé en particulier
sur cette question le droit de
l'emprunteur de résilier existe depuis
toujours avec l'article L13 122 le droit
de refus de substitution du contrat
d'assurance par le prêteur est
incompréhensible par l'emprunteur
d'autant que les offres de prêt courant
du marché qui régissent les liens
contractuels entre le prêteur et
l'emprunteur sur toute la durée du du
prêt stipule presque systématiquement
que depuis la loi la garde que
l'emprunteur est libre de choisir son
assurance de prêt et non a été libre
cette subtilité du droit de refus de
substitution a été déployée
insidieusement par les prêteurs en déni
toute l'égalité toute
contractualisation le rapporteur a
évoqué en commission l'analyse de
l'Inspection Générale des Finances qui
estime qu'un droit de substitution
annuel pendant toute la durée du prêt
pourra pourrait avoir des effets
négatifs or selon l'association de
consommateurs précité des banques le
pratiquent dès à présent et ne constate
pas de différence significative par
contre le nombre d'emprunteurs qui
souhait disposer d'un contrat plus riche
en garantie moins onéreux ou ne plus
subir les afes d'une sélection médicale
à l'entrée qui leur fut préjudiciable
compte tenu de leur faible recul sur un
antécédent médical alimentant le
médiateur alimente le médiateur de la
FFSA plus que les contrats automobiles
présentant pourtant TR 300 fois plus de
sinistres nous proposons de nous vous
proposons donc de prévoir qu'au-delà de
la période de 12 mois en cas d'exercice
par l'emprunteur du droit de résiliation
d'un contrat d'assurance du groupe ou
individuel mentionné à l'article l131 du
Code des assurances ou au premier
alinéat de l'article l12110 du code de
la mutualité le prêteur ne peut pas
refuser en garantie un autre contrat
d'assurance dès lors que ce contrat
présente un niveau de garantie
équivalent au contrat d'assurance
précédemment en
vigueur merci amendement 238 rectifi
monsieur Dalier merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues écoutez voilà un moment
intéressant puisque je vais défendre le
même amendement que nos collègues
communistes qui vise à essayer de donner
effectivement la plus grande possibilité
au consommateur de choisir leur
assurance et de la changer et cela
s'appuie sur la véritable mise en
concurrence c'est peut-être là que le
paradoxe se trouve mais si effectivement
ce que nous propose le texte qui nous
est présenté et et et et la Commission
est une avancée par rapport à ce qui
existe ça me semble quand même une
avancée relativement
limitée les marges sur ces contrats sont
énormes on le sait pendant des années
elles ont fait j'allais dire le bonheur
des assureurs et souvent des banquiers
parce que ils travaillaient souvent main
dans la main sur ce type de sujet alors
vous allez donner la possibilité à
l'emprunteur pendant 12 mois de proposer
une autre assurance très bien mais à mon
avis enfin j'ai peur que ça ne change
pas grand-chose au bout du compte et je
suis assez étonné d'entendre un certain
nombre de nos collègues se demander s'il
faut 12 mois 6 mois 3 mois ayant peur du
démarchage mais le démarchage c'est
d'abord la concurrence madame linman ce
qu'il nous faut pour faire baisser les
prix et que pour que les consommateurs
en profitent c'est bien évidemment qu'il
y ait de la concurrence entre les
assureurs à garantie équivalente bien
évidemment alors 12 mois moi je dire ça
me va très bien ce que je souhaiterais
c'est que au-delà de ces 12 mois
effectivement l'emprunteur ait la
liberté de proposer un contrat proposant
les mêmes garanties et si c'est un tarif
plus avantageux pour lui et bien tant
mieux merci amendement 60 rectifié
monsieur
Fortassin pardon monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
actuellement le dispositif de l'article
19S prévoit qu'au-delà de la période de
12 mois durant laquelle l'assuré peut
substituer son contrat d'assurance
emprunteur sans aucune pénalité ce sont
les clauses contractuelles qui régissent
les conditions dans lesquelles cette
substitution est possible très
précisément l'alinéa 6 prévoit
qu'au-delà de la période de 12 mois
susventionné le contrat ne peut prévoir
une faculté de substitution du contrat
d'assurance en cas d'exercice par
l'emprunteur du droit de résiliation
d'un contrat d'assurance de groupe ou
individuel or si l'on veut réellement
faciliter la mobilité assurancielle en
matière d'assurance emprunteur afin de
permettre aux assurés de bénéficier de
meilleures conditions il convient de
s'assurer qu'au-delà du délai de
substitution prévu par la loi les
contrats définissent effectivement les
conditions dans lesquelles une telle
substitution peut s'opérer tel est
l'objet de cet amendement j'ajouterai
que sous prétexte de concurrence ce qui
est bien il y a beaucoup de gens qui se
font
gruger par des personnes indélicates et
il faut faire très attention au travers
bien entendu de ce que nous décidons de
ne pas faciliter ces
pratiques
merci amendement identique 73 madame
Liman obligé d'avoir dans les contrats
les conditions de la résiliation après
la date permis de résiliation spontanée
c'est-à-dire en clair dans le dans
l'article 19 OC on dit le contrat peut
prévoir et je propose qu'on dise le
contrat défini ensuite on dit dans ce
cas les modalités d'application de la
faculté de substitution sont définies
dans le contrat de prêt je pense que
l'état d'esprit c'est permettre la
résiliation au début du contrat mais
aussi de clarifier les conditions de la
résiliation après cette date de 12 mois
donc je propose que ce soit une
obligation de l'écrire clairement dans
le contrat les modalités de résiliation
et les conditions dans lequell ça doit
pouvoir se faire merci 214 Monsieur Le
Cam très brièvement monsieur le
Président mon ministre cher collllègu
c'est un amendement de repli par lequel
nous vous proposons d'étendre le droit
de substitution des emprunteurs au-delà
du délai de 12 mois en clarifiant les
conditions dans lesquelles la banque ne
pourrait pas s'y
opposer merci amendement 310 monsieur
corneu
oui monsieur le Président si vous le
permettez je vais défendre 310 311 et
312 puisque le 311 et 312 finalement
sont des amendements de conséquence par
rapport au au 310 en fait le le présent
donc le 310 le présent amendement vise à
préciser que le droit à résiliation
offert pendant une certaine période donc
on va se mettre d'accord sur la période
à compter de la signature de l'offre de
crédit ne peut être exercé qu'une seule
fois sur cette
période dans la mesure où le but de
cette période est de permettre aux
assureurs qui veulent se positionner sur
le marché d'avoir le temps de prospecter
les nouveaux clients cette période est
suffisante pour permettre une surenchère
d'offre or on ne peut pas sans
conséquence déstabiliser la garantie
associée au contrat de crédit en
permettant à l'emprunteur de la changer
deux trois fois pendant la première anné
de contrat il faut quand même bien sûr
faciliter au consommateurs mais il faut
quand même faire attention quoi
pas merci je vais donc demander
rapporteur l'avis de la commission sur
ces 11
amendements ça va assez vite qu ce que
j'ai dit au départ donc sur le 308
défavorable sur le 56 rectifié c'est
histoire des 3 mois et cetera
défavorable sur le 216 et 238 identique
défavorable sur le
63 au-delà des 12 mois c'est le principe
de la liberté contractuelle qui
s'applique une faculté additionnelle de
substitution au-delà de 12 mois peut
être prévu si cette faculté est
effectivement accordée elle devit être
préciseée dans le contrat en revanche si
aucune disposition spécifique n'est
prévue au contrat cela implique que
cette facilité n'est pas accordée à
priori par le prêteur de son client donc
donc
défavorable et le 310 également
défavorable par la même occasion
défavorable quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre bon même avis quelques quelques
mots quand même sur des questions un peu
précises la question de Monsieur Cornu
sur la sur le fait de savoir si on
renvoyait pas euh au décret pour les
éléments essentiels du droit des
contrats c'est la loi et c'est ce qui
justifie que ce soit inscrit euh dans la
loi quelques mots sur la question du
démarchage mais incontestablement si on
peut faire jouer la concurrence comment
la fera--on jouer de manière à permettre
à ce qu'un certain nombre d'assureurs
qui aujourd'hui Assur bon nombre de
Français en MRH ou en assurance auto
quand ils verront le changement
d'adresse de leurs clients et bien leur
proposeront peut-être une assurance
emprunteur qui permettra à ces
consommateurs de comparer entre ce
qu'ils ont le le le contrat qu'ils ont
souscrit et le contrat qu' leurit
proposé et ce démarchage sera utile
effectivement pour que des facto la
concurrence joue et et donc les prix
baissent c'est la raison pour laquelle
je crois pas que pendant l'année qui va
suivre le changement
d'adresse les Français soient d'abord
sous couvert de proposition d'assureur
ils en auront mais ils auront la
capacité là de pouvoir étalonner ce que
sont les les offres des uns et des
autres et ça va dans dans le bon sens
pourquoi le délai de 12 mois pourquoi
pas plus court pourquoi pas plus plus
long le 12 mois je dit sur nous voulons
que le temps soit suffisant pour pouvoir
apprécier euh la situation et changé le
cas échéant de contrat et donc résilier
le contrat initial ce que je voudlais
dire aussi c'est que par rapport à la
question de la mutualisation du risque
il est clair que soyons honnête pour une
personne qui aura souscrit à un prêt
donc à une assurance emprunteur et qui
juste après ce prê tomberait gravement
malade pour elle la concurrence fera pas
baisser dans ce cas-là les prix c'est à
contest mais dans un délai d'un an on
peut supposer que les risques de tomber
très gravement malades par par rapport
au moment où on a signé le prêt et
l'assurance emprunteur sont quand même
relativement réduits c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons pris un délai
suffisamment long mais en même temps pas
non plus trop long trop long au au au au
point de de de faire courir le risque
d'une démutualisation et qui aurait là
des conséquence je le redis pour un
certain nombre de population qui serait
tout à fait préoccupante sur l'accès
donc assez près donc la possibilité
d'engager pour elle des dépenses donc
voilà je les quelques points sur lequels
je voulais apporter des précisions mais
conformément à ce que je vous avait dit
en ouverture de ce débat l' viis du
gouvernement sera conforme à celui du
rapporteur retrait ou défavorable à tous
ces amendements qui visent ou à allonger
ou à raccourcir le délis proposé de 12
mois merci monsieur le ministre je vais
donc mettre au voie l'amendement 308
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté je suppose
que le vote sera le même pour les 10
autres amendements
même vote ils ne sont pas adoptés nous
passons donc à l'amendement 285 rectifié
madame
procacia merci monsieur le Président
nous avons évoqué tous le problème de du
délai cette amendement vise à fixer une
effectivité de 12 mois à partir du
paiement de la première échéance du prêt
parce que vous pouvez signer le contrat
mais avoir mensualité qui commence à
être débité un mois peut-être un mois et
demi ou 2 mois après donc le délai de 12
mois n'est plus un véritable délai comme
c'est prévu dans la loi comme le
souhaite l'original originellement le le
texte de loi donc cet amendement a
simplement pour but de de dire que les
12 mois seront bien effectif à
partir du prêt et non pas de la
signature du prêt mais de la première
échéance
di près merci avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur un propos
introductif vous aviez dit que vous
étiez assez pessimiste vous aviez raison
parce que c'est la même réponse qu'il a
4 mois voilà défavorable merci avu du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre même
avis même avis je le mets au voix quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté amendement
239 rectifié monsieur Dallier merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement est identique dans le
principe à l'un de ceux que la Haute
Assemblée avait euh adopté avec l'avis
favorable du Gouvernement d'ailleurs au
moment de la du vote de la loi sur la
régulation des activités bancaires et
c'est un amendement de clarification euh
en effet lorsque l'on parle des délais
qui sont qui courent au moment de la
signature du prêt ou alors au moment de
la présentation d'un nouveau contrat
d'assurance par emprinteur euh on parle
de jours ouvré alors que partout
ailleurs lorsqu'on fait référence par
exemple à la validité de de l'offre de
prêt euh aussi bien qu'au délais
discrivnaire on parle de jour calendaire
donc je propose simplement
d'homogénéiser pour une plus grande
clarté euh pour l'emprunteur et pour les
deux parties et donc de supprimer le mot
ouvrer euh pour ne faire référence qu'à
des jours
calendaires merci avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur alors je rappelle
qu'un jour ouvral est un jour de semaine
non férier consacré au travail le samedi
éant un jour ouvrable les jours ouvrés
sont des jours réels d'ouverture
d'entreprise selon les secteurs
d'activités des jours ouvrés vari par
exemple les agences bancaires et cetera
l'amendement se traduirait donc par une
diminution des délais accordés au
consommateurs pour exercer leur libre
leur liberté de choix avis défavorable
merci avis du gouvernement monsieur même
avis monsieur le merci je mets donc au
voix l'amendement 239 rectifi monsieur
daller je vous en
prie on était sur juste juste un mot
monsieur le président de commission on
était me semble-t-il ou alors je me
trompe mais je ne pense pas sur le délai
que la banque avait pour répondre à
l'emprunteur et pas le contraire et pas
le contraire donc on souhaitait
effectivement que le délai donné à la
banque soit le plus court possible c'est
tout donc on l'avait adopté avec avis
favorable du gouvernement c'est
exactement la même question sur la loi
de régulation bancaire on était sur la
substitution avant la signature du
contrat donc à l'époque le gouvernement
était d'accord la commission aussi et là
on est sur le D des 12 mois et on ne
serait plus d'accord bon je trouve que
c'est pas cohérent j'espère que non mais
j'espère qu'on me suivra que la la Haute
Assemblée me
suivra merci je vais donc mettre au cet
amendement quels sont ceux qui sont pour
son
adoption avis
contraire non il n'est pas
adopté amendement 286 rectifié madame
procassia euh cet amendement vise à
imposer au prêteur une information
écrite de sa décision d'accepter ou de
refuser un autre contrat d'assurance
parce que que va-t-il se passer le
l'emprunteur peut recevoir simplement un
coup de téléphone de son banquier qui va
lui dire ben non j'accepte pas ou
j'accepte ou alors tout simplement
revenez me voir on va tout renégocier et
on peut revoir un certain nombre de
choses donc c'est simplement une précise
pas une modification monsieur le
rapporteur du texte en disant par un
écrit écrit
motivé merci avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur il a 4 mois avis
défavorable satisfait à la loi bancaire
merci avis du gouvernement même avis
même avis je le mets au voix quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire il n'est pas
adopté amendement 200 192 rectifié
madame
procaia
euh il vise à lorsque l'emprunteur a
souscrit un contrat par sa banque par
exemple un contrat groupe et que dans le
délai d'un an il va pouvoir souscrire
éventuellement un autre contrat auprès
qui peut être non pas un contrat groupe
cette fois-ci l'amendement vise à imposé
un délai de 10 jours pour informer
l'emprunteur de la décision
d'accepter ou non cette notification
dans le délai de 10 jours est en fait
considéré sans réponse dansun délai de
jours la excusez-moi le nouveau contrat
est considéré comme accepté il faut bien
voir que en matière de prêt et en
particulier quand c'est les vacances et
quand c'est les vacances d'été les
délais sont insupportable et on vous
répond pas forcément dans les dans les
dans les bons
créneaux mettre des créneaux permettrait
que les banquiers ou les assureurs
puissent effectivement se dire le délai
de 10 jour que le responsable du dossier
soit présent ou pas des pas présent il
faut quand même bien l'assurer merci
avis de la
commission c'est une excellente idée
donc on a eu la même je vous suggérerai
de vous vous vous replier sur
l'amendement du rapporteur c'est le 345
je pense voilà merci merci avis même
avis même avis il est retiré madame il
est retiré
merci amendement 313 qu'il défend
monsieur Cornu
on a on a bien compris que c'était
difficile d'avoir des amendements avec
avis favorable même quand on voulait
simplifier clarifier là je vous propose
un amendement de
clarification donc cet amendement vise à
clarifier la disposition concernant
l'avenant au contrat de prêt initial en
effet le le renvoi à l'article euh sus
nommé du Code de la Consommation est
suffisant dans la mesure où cette
disposition prévoit déjà que l'avenant
au contrat de prêt comprend le taux
effectif global ainsi que le coût du
crédit calculé sur la base des seules
échéances et frais
àenir merci avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur on supprime une
information en direction du consommateur
don avis défavorable avis du
même avis merci je le mets au voix quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire il n'est pas
adopté amendement 344 de la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur c'est un amendement de
précision rappelant que pour l'émission
d'un avenant le coût de l'assurance doit
être exprimé en taux annuel effective de
l'assurance tea un montant total du 1 €
sur la durée totale du prêt 1 période en
montant total du en euros sur la durée
totale du prêt et en euros par période
ce taux facilite les comparaison d'offre
de prêt donc c'est une précision merci
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
favorable merci je mets donc au voit
l'amendement de la commission quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire il n'y en a pas
il est adopté deux amendements
identiques le 62 rectifié monsieur
Fortassin monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues toujours
sur la question de l'assurance
emprunteur cet amendement vise à
préciser la rédaction de l'article 3129
du Code de la Consommation il prévoit
que lorsque le prêteur accepte que
l'emprunteur soit couvert par un contrat
d'assurance autre que le contrat de
groupe qui lui propose il ne peut exiger
en contrepartie des frais
supplémentaires pour l'émission d'un
avenant au contrat de prêt lorsque cet
avenant concerne une uniquement une
modification d'assurance
merci 74 madame
lienman merci avis de la
commission favorable la loi c'est le
contrat donc avis défavorable pour les
deux merci avis du gouvernement monsieur
le
ministre je proposer volontiers à Madame
linman et au groupe RDSE de de retirer
puisque les frais d'Aven au contrat de
consécutif un changement de contrat
d'assurance emprunteur dans le délai de
12 mois sont déjà interdits votre
amendement est donc
déjà satisfait concernant la gratuité de
ses avenant au-delà de la période de 12
mois c'est la liberté contractuelle qui
s'applique donc là le prêteur peut on
faire un argument commercial s'il le
veut en prévoyant une possibilité
additionnelle de substitution s'il le
souhaite mais je tel quel il est il est
satisfait donc je demanderai de bien
vouloir le retirer sinon défavorable
merci les amendements sont retirés
monsieur Fortassin madame linman ils
sont
retirés quatre amendements identies 215
Monsieur Le Cam ah non pardon madame
Church merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
lorsque les emprunteurs demandent à
changer d'assurance en cours de prêt ils
sont aujourd'hui totalement exposé au
bon vouloir de leur banque prêteuse même
si leurs motifs sont parfaitement
sérieux alors parmi ces motifs
difficultés financière qui les conduit à
optimiser leurs dépenses ou volonté de
disposer de meilleures garanties ou
leurs conditions d'acception lorsqu'ils
étaient peut-être en risque aggravé de
santé au moment de la souscription du
crédit c'est pourquoi nous considérons
que le projet de loi pourrait améliorer
la situation de ces
emprunteurs cependant aucune disposition
ne sanctionne le non respect de ces
nouveaux droits donc par notre
amendement nous vous proposons
d'inscrire dans la loi que le refus
infondé ou hors délai d'une demande
d'assurance déléguée ou le non respect
du délai pour la réémission de l'offre
de de prêt expose le prêteur à une
amende administrative de 3000
€ l'amendement 345 de la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur c'est l'amendement 345 va
exactement dans votre votre sens donc et
ça permettra de faire également si vous
Z d'accord le 240 et le le
61 seraiit satisfait par la même donc
c'est une amende de 3000 €
voilà merci le 240 monsieur Dalier merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre pour une fois j'ai un avis
favorable du rapporteur quel bonheur
donc étant donné que mon amendement est
effectivement exactement le même que le
sien et que celui de notre collègue du
groupe
CRC que manifestement l'un ou l'autre
sont adoptés je vais pouvoir m'y
rallier merci 61 rectifié monsieur
Fortassin il est défendu merci je vais
donc mettre au voix ces quatre
amendements en demandant d'abord l'avis
de la commission sur le
215 il est retiré il vous avez demandé
le retrait
pardonnez-moi alors avis du Gouvernement
sur ce cet amendement du Gouvernement
est favorable à l'amendement du du
rapporteur ce qui par voitre conséquence
m mène à inviter monsieur Fortassin
monsieur Dalier et C Monsieur Le Cam qui
avait déposé l'amendement à retirer le
leur merci Madame chch il est retiré il
est retiré donc le 345 de la commission
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre favorable favorable merci je
mets donc au voix madame procacia pour
explication de vote
pardonnez-moi monsieur le rapporteur
vous m'aviez dit que mon amendement
était satisfait il est très
indirectement satisfait parce qu'il y a
une pénalité moi ce que je proposais
c'est que sans réponse il était le
contrat était réputé le nouveau contrat
réputé accepté or là il faut se lancer
dans une procédure et des
délais merci je mets donc au voie l'avis
de la commission l'amendement de la
commission 345 quels sont ceux qui sont
pour son adoption avis contraire il est
adopté et donc les deux suivants sont
satisfaits nous en arrivons à
l'amendement 70 madame lienman
ah
voilà il s'agit là de la proposition que
le rapporteur a déjà décidé de ne pas
retenir je dois dire que je ne crois pas
avoir une grande audition de l'Assemblée
mais je pense que à terme il est
fondamental de d'acter dans la loi le
principe de la mutualisation alors là
c'est évidemment un peu le Mart pilon
pour acter cette mutualisation puisque
de fait il y en a elle est obligatoire
vu qu'il y aurait plus de critères d'âge
et de critères socio-économiques mais
euh je retire donc mon amendement au
regard de la position du rapporteur en
revanche je ferai des propositions qui
pour les prêts à caractère très sociaux
offre un conventionnement qui va déjà
dans cet esprit si vous nous présentez
le 72 madame
Liman donc là
là que cette proposition serait
extrêmement importante pour garantir que
les accédents modestes à la population à
la à l'accession à la propriété puisse
avoir une assurance emprunteur qui soit
pas chère et qui soit fiable parce que
vous savez qu'il y a plusieurs problèmes
quand on choisit cette assurance c'est
les conditions réelles d'assurance la
prise en compte des ITT la prise en
compte des difficultés les vraies
garanties donc je propose qu'il y ait
une assurance conventionnée pour tous
les prêt passe PTZ et tous les prêts
aidés par l'État le PSLA ou les prêts
conventionnés ce qui aurait un double
avantage protéger l'accédent lui donner
un socle de protection garanti et par
ailleurs pouvoir avoir des tarifs qui
tirent vers le bas les prix puisqu'on
aurait par ce conventionnement un effet
prix global comparatif pour le reste du
marché donc je pense que c'est une façon
de réguler le marché de protéger les
accédents qui pas de nature à
déstabiliser un marché vous savez que
les marges monsieur Dali en a parlé sont
assez substantielles et serait donc
nécessaire de mieux contrôler et
encadrer merci quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
simplement comme remarque quelquefois
les les emprunteurs ont des prêts sur
les prêts aidés ont également des prêts
concurrentiels me semble être une
solution ce que vous proposez me semble
extrêmement complexe donc avis
défavorable merci avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre même avis merci je
mets au voix l'amendement 72 quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis
contraire quels sont ceux qui sont pour
son adoption avis contraire il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 172 est retiré et
nous arrivons à trois amendements en
discussion commune dont le 314 qu'il
présente Madame l mur merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues cet amendement vise à préciser
l'articulation entre la résiliation de
l'ancienne assurance et la prise d'effet
de la nouvelle parce qu'en effet ce que
l'on constate dans le texte c'est que
plusieurs délais se chevau il y a le
premier qui dit le prêteur notifié à
l'emprunteur sa décision d'acceptation
ou de refus dans un délai de 10 jours à
compter de la réception d'un autre
contrat assurance présentant un niveau
de garantie équivalent dans un deuxième
point le prêteur émet un avenant au
contrat de crédit qui donne à
l'emprunteur toujours un dél de
réflexion de 10 jours mais à compter de
la réception des informations et enfin
il est dit qu'en cas d'acceptation par
le prêteur la résiliation du contrat
d'assurance prend effet toujours 10
jours après mais après la réception par
l'assureur de la décision du prêteur on
peut donc on peut donc exclure le risque
que l'empruntante soit pas couvert
pendant une certaine période entre la
résiliation de l'ancienne assurance et
la prise d'effet de la nouvelle donc cet
amendement vise à lier ces deux
événements pour assurer la sécurité de
l'emprunteur et garantir la créance du
prêteur nous pensons donc qu'il est
indispensable qu'un décret Vienne
préciser les conditions d'application de
cette disposition c'est l'objet de cet
amendement merci le 287 rectifié madame
procassia il est même s'il est un peu
différent dans la même V que celui
présenté par Monsieur dier euh ici nous
savons ce que c'est que les jours
ouvrables les jours ouvrés et cetera
mais l'emprunteur qui lit son contrat
sans précision aura peut-être du mal à
faire les calculs donc il vise à
préciser clairement qu'il s'agit de jour
ouvré
euh pour que l'information soit comprise
de toutes merci le 358 du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
oui je je vais vous présenter
l'amendement du Gouvernement qui
m'amènera vu que c'est le même sujet à à
donneré un avis défavorable ou à
suggérer le retrait à Madame procass et
à Madame Lamur pour leurs amendements
respectif donc cet amendement 358 a pour
objet de mieux sécuriser la procédure de
substitution d'un contrat d'assurance
emprunteur par un autre présentant un
niveau de garantie équivalent il
sécurise à la fois le prêteur et
l'emprunteur il est ainsi prévu que la
résiliation du contrat d'assurance
n'intervienne pas avant la date de prise
d'ffets du contrat qui lu est substitué
cette précision est protectrice à la
fois pour le prêteur qui sera ainsi
certain de conserver la la garantie au
prêt qu'il a accordé mais aussi pour
l'emprunteur qui aura qui sera certain
d'être toujours assuré pendant la
procédure de substitution l'emprunteur
qui souhaite résilier son contrat devra
notifier à son ancien assureur la date
de prise d'ffit du contrat accepté en
substitution en même temps que la
décision du prunteur du prêteur pardon
l'emprunteur sera protégé car il y aura
une courte période de chevauchement
entre les deux assurances si la date de
prise d'effet du nouveau contrat est
inférieure 10 jours après son envoi ou
si la date de prise d'effet du nouveau
contrat est postérieure à 10 jours après
son envoi la résiliation interviendra au
moment où le nouveau contrat prendra
effet dans tous les cas il y aura
continuité des deux contrats cette
précision sera transposée dans le code
des assurances et dans le code de la
mutualité merci avis de la commission
sur ces trois amendements monsieur le
rapporteur donc pour le 314 de Madame l
mur donc nous avions décidé d'inroger le
gouvernement il y a un amendement qui
est déposé donc on y bien entendu
favorable et je vous demand le retrait
pour le
287 même réponse que pour Monsieur
Dalier tout à l'heure donc avis
défavorable et pour le l'amendement du
Gouvernement avis favorable avis
favorable merci beaucoup les amendements
sont retirés madame
procacia madame Lamur oui monsieur le
Président nous ce que ce que l'on
souhaitait par cet amendement c'est
vraiment qu'il n'y ait pas de de période
dans le le le le la passation des deux
contrats qu'il n'y ait pas de période
pendant laquelle l'emprunte ne serait
pas couvert donc je crois avoir compris
que l'amendement du Gouvernement y
répond donc je j'accepte de retirer
celui-ci merci Madame procacia aussi
alors madame procaen vous savez c'est
Saint-Thomas elle croit quece qu'elle
touche voi j'ai pas vraiment eu le temps
de regarder complètement ce que disait
le gouvernement dans l'exposé des motifs
du ministre ça me convient bien mais
j'attire son attention puisque j'ai pas
la prétention de le faire changer d'avis
que chauauchement ça veut dire qu'il va
payer deux fois des intérêts il paiera
avec les deux assurances des intérêts
est-il bien prévenu ou je vois les
conseillers qui font la tête la tête de
droite à gauche si c'est non et bien ça
serait bien en tout cas qu'il ait pas
besoin de payer deux fois et dans
l'amendement de que présentait madame
Lamur euh j' elle faisait référence
quand même à des notions qui est
différentes et incompatibles l'idée on
est dans un texte consceo c'est que les
choses soient bien claires donc est-ce
que dans la rédaction que propose euh le
ministre ces notions qui sont évoquées
qui sont trois fois différentes sont le
problème est bien réglé sinon je retire
mon amend merci est retiré je mets donc
au voix l'amendement du Gouvernement 358
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis
contraire il est adopté amendement 69
madame
linman cet amendement V rendre
impossible le paiement enin d'interdire
le paiement des frais d'intermédiaire
quand il y a substitution d'un
contrat par le par l'emprunteur parce
que en fait dans la concurrence quand
vous regardez les prix vous vous dites
ah bah ça coûte beaucoup moins cher
notamment les frais de commission mais
sauf que quand vous regardez que par
ailleurs vous devez payer le courtier et
l'intermédiaire vous vous retrouvez
souvent avec des prix supérieur donc
pour la clarté il et et dans la logique
de ce qui est prévu habituellement il
revient au mutuel aux assurances de
payer le courtier et non pas
l'emprunteur voilà le but de mon
amendement merci avis de la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur j'estime qu' qu' a un risque
pour le pour l'emprunteur donc de du
fait que l'assurance
l'assureur vienne prendre prendre sur
l'emprunteur l'argent qu'il aura
perdu sur voilà
à mon avis à mon avis il y a un risque
me semble-t-il donc j'ai avis plutôt
défavorable merci avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre même avis je mets
donc madame
lenman je dois dire que quand on fait le
bilan aujourd'hui de la situation vous
avez les assureurs qui reçoivent le
double de ce qu'il percevaient dans le
cadre des contrat groupe par contre les
courtiers qui sont en revanche moins
rémunérés par l'assureur se rattrapent
sur les emprunteurs en leur faisant
payer des frais et il cumulent ainsi la
Commission et l'honoraire donc monsieur
le rapporteur pour ma part l'analyse
qu'on m'a donné de la situation n'est
pas le risque que vous indiquez mais
plutôt le risque inverse cela dit si le
gouvernement et le rapporteur sont
hostiles je retirerai mon amendement
mais je vous demande monsieur le
ministre de bien y être vigilant pour
l'avenir parce qu' là manifestement des
risques de dérive merci les tirez vous
nous présentez le 71 madame
lenman celui-là je le retire pas
pas pourquoi nous avons besoin on l'a
dit il y a beaucoup de Marg dans ces
contrats d'assurance et c'est très
difficile pour les les qui prennent le
contrat d'assurance de savoir
réellement combien de profit est fait
sur leur assurance comment les frais se
répartissent et qui paye de fait donc je
propose que pour les assurances de
groupe ayant pour objet la garantie de
remboursement d'un emprunt la notice
comprenne en annexe un rapport sur les
comptes de la convention du contrat en
cours des CIN exercices annuels
précédents ce rapport doit détailler le
mentau des cotisations des prestations
payées des provisions techniques des
frais de gestion et d'acquisition des
autres charges et ressources internes
ainsi que les montants et les
bénéficiaires des participations au
résultats et des commissions versé à des
intermédiaires selon des modalités
précisées par arrêté du ministre chargé
de l'économie alors vous allez me dire
oh là là quelle Inquisition et ben non
puisque cette disposition existe pour
toutes les assurances de groupe
souscrites par des entreprises en vertu
de la Loi
1989 1909 ça me paraît un peu étonnant
oui bon bref 1909 en tout cas ça existe
déjà pour la loi pour les entreprises il
n'y a donc aucune raison que le logiciel
ne puisse pas fonctionner pour les
particuliers merci quel est l'avis de la
commission l'avis de la commission on a
parl en commission effectivement et on a
dit que on interrogait le gouvernement
alors quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement qui pas de chance parce que
le gouvernement s' remettait à la
commission non mais je
plaisante non nous avions trou prévu
j'avais même la fiche au cas où dans
alors plus sérieusement pour les
assurances emprunteur de groupe la
position du gouvernement est qu'annexé à
la notice un rapport sur les comptes de
la convention ou du contrat en cours des
CIN exercices annuels précédent ne
paraît pas nécessaire pour atteindre
l'objectif de transparence recherché par
vous-même nous demanderons pierre MICI
et moi-même à l'Autorité de contrôle
prudentiel et de résolution de procéder
par voie d'instruction pour demander aux
organismes assureurs la réalisation
d'états de reporting spécifique sur
l'assurance emprunteur cela permettra
d'améliorer la transparence sur le
niveau des prime et de sinistre de ces
contrats et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je considère que la
préoccupation qu'il a votre est
satisfaite et je vous demanderaiis
madame lindmann le retrait j'espère que
ainsi j'ai pu éclairer le rapporteur
également merci Madame
lunman ti pas parce que nous VO dans ces
sujets de transparence on a toujours les
grands experts qui ont des reporting et
moi je pense que vu la situation
d'ailleurs on le voit bien conflictuel
entre les assurances et les banques sur
ce sujet où il nous explique les uns et
les autres que toutes les turpitudes des
voisins il me semble qu'il serait
nécessaire que les les consommateurs
soient éclairés et que la transparence
soit la plus grande possible sur qui
paye quoi et comment se répartissent les
sommes payé donc je sais bien je
m'aintiens car je pense que je vais dans
le sens de l'histoire merci madame je
met donc au voix l'amendement 71 quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
alors
compte
av
comp avis
contraire il est adopté il est
adopté je vais donc mettre au vo
l'article 19 ocè est-ce qu'il y a des
demandes de prise de parole sur cet
article il n en a pas quels sont ceux
qui sont pour adopter l'article 19
ocès avis contraire il est adopté même
vote sur le 19 des
siè même vote sur le 19 des
siè même vote nous arrivons à l'article
B avec deux amendements
discussion commune pardon le 48 monsieur
Fortassin hein
oui le présent amendement vise à obliger
l'assureur qui résilie unilatéralement
un contrat avec un assuré à préciser le
montif exa de la résiliation cette
précision importante vise à mieux
protéger les assurés elle permettra
notamment d'éviter qu'un assuré don le
contrat est rompu sans sinistre
responsable et des difficultés à se
réassurer ù se voit demander sans aucune
justification une
surprim merci le 171 est retiré je vais
donc demander l'avis de la commission
sur le
48 monsieur le rapporteur 48 sur le 48
sur le 48 l'article 2 B r obligatoire la
modification de la résiliation et il
semble législativement plus raisonnable
de s'entenir au principe donc avis
défavorable merci av gouvernement
monsieur le ministre oui ma vie d'abord
il y a un équilibre qui avait été trouvé
en commission Sénat et à l'Assemblée
aujourd'hui tel quel sur les motifs de
résiliation qui sont contenus dans le
code des assurances vont au-delà de la
préoccupation qui vont les vôres donc
couvre à mes yeux le votre préoccupation
monsieur Fortassin c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous demanderai le retrait
merci il est retiré monsieur Fortassin
il est
retiré je vais mettre au voie l'article
20 B quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
avis contraire il est adopté article 21
avec une demande de prise de parole de
Madame
procasscia merci monsieur le Président
cet article 21 permet la résiliation
intra infraannuel des polices
d'assurance dès la première année vous
partez je me suis déjà exprimé lors de
la première lecture sur cet article sur
la sur lequel je suis toujours posé vous
partez monsieur le ministre du postulat
que la concurrence va entraîner une
baisse des prix de l'assurance je me
demande si vous avez reçu votre appel de
cotisation pour 2014 est-ce pour
anticiper euh les coûts de communication
de la concurrence les coûts
d'acquisition de nouveaux clients et
certes parce que un certain nombre de
risques et taxes se sont accumulé en
2013 mais en tout cas euh les
cotisations d'assurance ont augmenté
cette année pour tout le monde donc on
est un peu mal parti par rapport aux
objectifs de vot notre projet de loi je
le dis je me répète et en tout cas je
l'aurais dit si je ne suis pas à défaut
d'être entendu je ne crois pas que
l'assurée il gagnera au pouvoir d'achat
il PEA peut-être moins cher mais
sera-t-il vraiment garanti parce qu'il y
a une différence entre le prix et le
niveau de la garantie les assurances
habitation la responsabilité civile auto
ne pèse que 2,1 % monsieur le ministre
dans un ménage et non pas les 5 % que
vous nous aviez assuré en première
lecture je suis allé vérifier surtout et
je le dénonce une nouvelle fois c'est le
chiffre d'affaires des comparateurs
d'assurance que vous allez améliorer ce
qui se rémunèr au nombre de clics et aux
affaires même si heureusement vous avez
accepté un des
de et qui
a regardez si vous le faites et si vous
en avez le temps un petit peu la
télévision vous verrez qu'il n'y a plus
que des publicité de comparateurs
d'assurance automobile interrogez-vous
donc pourquoi Google a d'ailleurs tout
de suite après le vote en première
lecture annoncé le lancement de son
comparateur d' pour pouvoir vendre des
assurances il l'a momentanément retarder
mais pour combien de temps euh le cet
article 21 et donc votre loi introduit
donc la possibilité de résilier les
assurances au bout d'un an un peu près
comme on veut pour ces assurances je
sais quelle est votre conviction pour ma
part je continue à dénoncer cette clause
sélective de résiliation tac de tacite
reconduction pourquoi et uniquement sur
deux types de contrat d'assurance
d'ailleurs dans certaines autres branche
ils m'ont avoué en privé qu'ils ne
pensaient pas pouvoir échapper eux aussi
à la clause à la remise en cause de la
clause de tacite reconduction et bien si
pour l'instant ça ne s'applique qu' aux
assureurs et aux assureurs pour
l'habitation et pour la RC automobile
deuxème élément que je continue à
dénoncer la simplification je sais que
monsieur le rapporteur faucconniier
avait retoqué mes amendements parce
qu'il disait que ça complexifiait les
choses je continue à dire que ça ne
complexifie pas d'abord ça maintient la
situation actuelle et ça ne la
complexifie pas mais deuxièmement ça
sécurise l'assurée parce que qui pourra
prouver quand l'assureur de mauvaise foi
ou parce que le courrier se sera égaré
dira je n'ai jamais reçu votre lettre de
résiliation qui pourra prouver que
l'assurée est de bonne volonté en plus à
l'heure où les postiers se plaignent de
ne plus avoir de travail et ne plus
distribuer je pense que vous allez en
accentuer un petit peu plus le nombre de
de problèmes que rencontre la poste avec
son personnel hormis la lettre
recommandée il y a des moyens actuels de
résiliation avec des accusés de
réception comme les mails avec accusés
de réception comme les fax où il y a un
accusé de réception et tout ça vous le
voyez bien ne remet pas en cause du tout
la faculté de résiliation mais elle
permet de sécuriser l'assurer je
regrette et je regrette une nouvelle
fois parce que je sais que vous allez me
répondre la même chose que la qu'en
première lecture mais c'est pas pour
autant que je ne veux pas dénoncer et
que l'on pourra pas dire qu'ici au s il
y a au moins un sénateur qui a défendu
les assurés et qui sait comment ça se
passe sinon pour les
résiliations merci vous nous présentez
votre amendement 288 rectifi madame
procassia cet amendement vise à
clarifier le point le de 1 an à compter
duquel l'assuré peut résilier son
contrat d'assurance en l'absence de la
définition de terme souscription dans le
code des assurances prêter à des
confusions l'article l124 du même code
distingue de façon claire la date à
laquelle la police d'assurance est
étblie et celle à laquelle le risque est
garanti c'est-à-dire la date de prise
d'ffit du contrat l'objectif est de
permettre à l'assurée de résulier son
contrat au bout d'un an d'assurance avec
une précision terminologique qui
s'impose toujours dans la l'intérêt de
l'assuré av de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
donc il est déjà donné par Madame
procassia donc je la confirme
défavorable pour le 288 et défavorable
pour le 283 je maintiens que ça
complexifie le dispositif voilà merciel
est l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre sur le 288 rectifié même avis
mais c'est sans surprise c'estd que nous
avons une mesure qui est une mesure dont
nous pensons que pour qu'elle fonctionne
et qu'elle puisse faire baisser les
tarifs auquel s'assureent aujourd'hui
les Français en MRH et en d'assurance ao
auto pardon il faut que fluidifier ce
marché moi je me méfie je pense pas que
ce soit votre intention mais de forme de
petit caillou qui
s'amoncellerait dans ce processus que
nous voulons enclencher qui finalement
nuirait à l'objectif qui est de faire
baisser le prix des primes d'assurance
payé par les par par les Français donc
là nous nous maintenons que c'est
l'accord entre les parties le moment de
la souscription qui est le moment qui
doit être le moment de départ et pas la
date des fait parce qu'elle peut-être
postérieure au moment de la souscription
c'est la raison pour laquelle notamment
sur cet amendement et le suivant l'avis
du Gouvernement est défavorable merci je
vais donc mettre au voix l'amendement
288 rectifi quels sont ceux qui sont
pour son
adoption avis
contraire al on va le faire par ass
debout quels sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption du
quels sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté le 283
vous le présentez madame oui toujours
dans souci de sécurisation de de
l'assurer quand on souscrit une
assurance on la souscrit on envoie par
Internet où on signe un contrat mais il
y a une très nette différence entre le
moment où on souscrit et le moment où on
est assuré par exemple puisqu'on était
dans l'assurance habitation on était
dans l'habitation tout à l'heure un prêt
vous pouvez souscrire votre contrat
d'assurance pour l'appartement
d'ailleurs vous devez présenter quand
vous achetez un certificat d'assurance
pour l'appartement que vous allez avoir
dans un mois ou dans 2 mois donc la
souscription et l'assurance sont
complètement décalé et la assureur ne
vous fait pas payer le l'assurance au
moment de la souscription mais à partir
de la date de début donc euh à partir du
moment où l'on veut vraiment sécuriser
l'assurée il faut bien que ça parte à
partir du du paiement et non pas à
partir de la souscription qui est
complètement décalée dans le temps merci
je vais le mettre au voix puisque le
Gouvernement et la commission ont donné
un avis défavorable même vote que pour
le précédent il est refusé amendement 84
rectifié monsieur hon
oui on a parlé de de mutualisation là
c'est ça concerne les frais de rupture
anticipé du contrat puisque dans un
principe de liberté d'ouverture de
concurrence parfois je suis
surpris de la vitesse à laquelle
monsieur le ministre ou avec laquelle
vous vous engouffrez dans ces brèche
simplement ce que je propose c'est une
mesure de bon sens c'est-à-dire que le
marché dans ce domaine relativement
fluide puisque les études ont démontré
que près de 20 % des assurés changer de
contrat quel que soit le le le motif bah
il paraît assez logique puisque
lorsqu'on résilie un contrat ça engendre
des frais surtout dans cette
accélération je dirais puisque là au
bout d'un an de souscription il est
permis à tout moment de se retirer ce
qui perturbe quand même à mon avis ce
qui va perturber un peu le
fonctionnement et je trouve en tous les
cas et c'est l'objet de cet amendement
c'est de considérer que celui qui
modifie de son propre chef les
conditions pour pouvoir changer et bien
d'abord il supporte les frais euh en
propre lié à la résiliation ce qui
d'ailleurs ne me paraît pas
contradictoire avec l'éventuel gain de
pouvoir d'achat dont vous parlez puisque
j'imagine que dans la très grande
majorité des cas c'est pour payer moins
cher donc je ne trouve pas en plus que
ce consommateur assuré libre à tout
moment au-delà de la première année de
changer d'assureur je ne trouve pas
qu'il soit pénalisé dans son pouvoir
d'achat voilà donc je trouve que c'est
une forme de d'équité entre les assurés
et de justice de faire payer à celui ou
à celle qui souhait changer c'est
peut-être son droit mais c'est aussi
dans le parallisme des son devoir merci
avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur cet amendement vise à faire
supporter les frais administratifes li à
la résiliation hors échéance par celui
qui en bénéficie ce dispositif nous
semble de nature à constitué un frein à
la résiliation à tout moment voulu par
le projet de loi donc un avis plutôt
défavorable tout à fait défable merci
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre même même raisonnement que que
le rapporteur ce que nous voulons je le
redis je l'ai déjà dit mais nous voulons
que les assurés au terme de la première
année puisse résilier pas simplement
dans la fenêtre anniversaire du contrat
mais dès qu'il le souhaite au terme de
la première année notre objectif et nous
en sommes convaincus en dépis les
arguments d'un certain nombre de
professionnels mais dans les fait ça a
déjà commencé à changer et je m'en
réjouis c'est que parce que les Français
pourront beaucoup plus facilement passer
d'une d'un assureur à un autre en
matière de multirisque habitation ou
d'assurance auto qu'ils ne seront pas
obligés d'y penser au moment de la fin
fre anniversaire se rend compte qu'ils
ont parfois dépassé cette fenêtre
anniversaire et donc ça a été reconduit
automatiquement bref nous voulons que
dans ce cas-là nous puissions il puisse
bah faire fluidifier le marché et et
tout ce qui à travers des frais de
rupture anticipé finalement tend à là
encore mettre un petit caillou
supplémentaire et
à ne pas donner la la pleine mesure à
cette disposition de résiliation
infraannuelle des contrats d'assurance
pour pour faire baisser les prix et ben
à mon sens c'est négatif pour les
consommateurs raison pour laquelle je
donnerai un avis défavorable à cet
amendement merci je mets donc au voix
cet amendement monsieur pardon
oui oui pour explication moi moi
j'entends ce que vous venez de nous dire
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre je pense qu'il y a une une
certitude c'est que plus vous avez
d'opération plus ça entraîne de cout
donc votre conclusion au moins vous la
partagez et vous à revendiquer c'est ces
coûts supplémentaires sont supportés par
la col enfin je dirais le collectif des
assurés et non pas par celui ou celle
qui en fait la demande et monsieur le
ministre je veux vous redire une seconde
fois le le résonnement que je viens de
tenir en général si vous résiliez c'est
parce que vous trouvez moins cher
dontacte donc il ne serait pas choquant
parce que ça ne pénalise pas puisque
c'est un libre choix individuel enfin
j'attire notre attention je l'avaz fait
vous vous en souvenez peut-être pas mais
dans la la la première partie de
l'examen en première lecture je pense en
même temps que c'est la porte ouverte à
d'autres types d'assurance individuelles
et on aura à mon avis dans les années
qui viennent l'occasion d'en reparler
voilà je vous remercie merci Monsieur le
Ministre juste dire que je connais cet
argument il est utilisé par les
fédérations d'assureurs que de dire
votre loi parce qu'elle va mettre
davantage de concurrence et permettre au
français changer plus facile plus
facilement d'assurance va augmenter les
coûts on pense que c'est exactement le
contraire et que dans ce domaine là vous
l'avez évoqué il y a effectivement des
renouvellements vous évoquez le chiffre
de 20 % mais c'est pas beaucoup et et en
réalité c'est tellement peu que 8 Fran
sur 10 aujourd'hui quand on les
interroge voulez-vous avoir la
possibilité de résilier à la date de
votre choix votre contrat d'assurance et
pas être obligé
d'attendre tous les ans la fenêtre
anniversaire nous disent oui alors
peut-être que 8 Français sur 10 sont
ignorant et que vous êtes plus
intelligent que 80 % des Français mais
nous nous faisons confiance dans la vie
de 80 % des Français sur cette question
de l'assurance et de la concurrence mais
vous êtes vous êtes logique avec vous
défendez le point de vue des assureurs
ça se défend parfaitement mais moi je
préfère défendre le point de vue
désassuré monsieur
hon merci je mets donc au voie
l'amendement 84 rectifié quels sont ceux
qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire il n'est pas
adopté nous arriv à trois amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
le 284 rectifié madame
procacia bien le 284 a déjà été euh
présenté puisque il s'agit de sécuriser
les assurés mais je
peux déjà dire la réponse de du
rapporteur et du ministre ça complexifie
moi je dis que ça sécurise l'assurée et
que la lettre recommandé elle peut se
faire sur Internet les mail ça peut se
faire aussi tout autre moyen qui
prouvera qu'il y a effectivement eu
envoie d'une lettre en tout cas sans ces
élémentsl je suis sûre que nous allons
rentrer dans des séries de contentieux
merci avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur avis défavorable merci même
avis du gouvernement même avis même avis
je mets au voix
l'amendement pardon il y a le 83 qui est
en discussion commune qui le présente
monsieur Husson
ou il me semblait bien je je vous
laissais monsieur le Président animé
alors c'est exactement la même chose moi
vous savez monsieur le ministre je suis
pour les droits et devoirs
et ce qui va s'en dire va mieux encore
en l'écrivant et quand vous avez un
justificatif vous éit toute source de
contentieux en tous les cas quand vous
alleevez au final devant les tribunaux
vous avez un justificatif qui est
incontournable puisque la lettre
recommandée elle passe je dirais par un
tiers je ne suis pas du tout un grand
utilisateur et spécialiste du
tripatouillage informatique mais il
arrive assez souvent de voir que on vous
on est capable aujourd'hui de vous
fournir des je dirais des fac similés de
documents qui correspondrait quasiment à
des originaux malheureusement qui n'en
sont pas donc je crois que sur des
éléments comme ceuxla et quand vous
parlez de multirisque habitation
notamment ou de véhicules c'est pas
forcément des sommes mineures puisque
vous prenez le cas d'un incendie d'une
catastrophe naturelle qui peut engendrer
on va dire par effet rebond euh des
sinistres de grande envergure donc il
faut faire attention je crois que
comment dirais-je cette demande d'une
lettre recommandée en tous les cas ce
support qui est celui qui existe
aujourd'hui devrait monsieur le ministre
attirer votre attention puisque j'ai
bien noté que vous étiez aussi en charge
du droit de la consommation et du
respect des consommateurs donc je devine
que vous allez enfin y être favorable
merci le 57 rectifié monsieur
mard je l'
précipite
alors merci Monsieur le Ministre cet
amendement a un objectif simple
qui est partagé par nos collègues
auteurs des autres amendements en
discussion avec celui-ci il s'agit pour
nous de protéger les consommateurs et
plus particulièrement ici les
assurer l'article 21 du projet de loi
instaure une possibilité de résiliation
infraannuelle des assurance après un
engagement nous sommes tout à fait
favorables à cette mesure car elle vise
à faciliter le changement d'assurance et
à renforcer la concurrence afin de faire
baisser les prix dans l'intér des
consommateurs et et nous réjouissons
d'ailleurs que les députés ce qui est
rare et cher et repris en seconde
lecture une proposition portée par le
groupe RDSE au Sénat en première lecture
prévoyant que le nouvel assureur
effectue les formalités de résiliation
auprès de l'ancienne assureur pour le
compte de l'assurée cependant le fait
que l'assurée puisse résilier son
contrat par lettre simple ou tout autre
support durable nous semble très peu
sécurisant et afin de mieux le protéger
et d'éviter un certain nombre de
contentieux nous proposons donc avec cet
amendement que la résiliation se fasse
par lettre recommandée merci quel est
l'avis de la commission sur le 57 et le
284 puisque et le 83 pardon pour les
trois même s'ils sont totalement
identiques il y a le même
avis parce que ça complexifie les choses
et il y a cette loi une exigence de
simplicité simplifi
et comme l' dit Monsieur l'assureur le
Nouel assureur doit faire le job donc il
y a pas de raison de compliquer les
choses voilà un avis défavorable gouvern
ministreurésident comprends l'objectif
mais nous considérons aussi que c'est
contraignant coûteux désincitatif en
quelque sorte à réser son contrat
d'assurance c'est la raison pour
laquelle comme en première lecture
gouvernement est constant sur cette
position donne avis
défavorable merci je mets donc au voix
ces amendements commençant par 284
rectifiés quels sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption du 284
rectifiés avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté même vote
pour les deux autres même vote ils ne
sont pas adoptés et nous arrivons au 85
rectifiés monsieur Husson
oui monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur il
s'agit là voyez j'ai j'ai pris un ce qui
pourrait être un cas pratique c'est
d'être attentif aux questions du
renouvellement alors évidemment vous
avez bien compris que dans mon cas
pratique qui n'est qu'un exemple c'est
un renouvellement qui se passe juste au
bout de la première année et puis avec
une survenance répétée et courte de
sinistre je rappelle simplement que dans
la faculté que vous offrez d'une liberté
des
après le renouvellement de la première
échance annuelle je veux aussi rappeler
que les modalités parce que parfois les
assurés confondent la durée annuelle
actuellement tacite reconduction et la
garantie par paiement mensuel le
paiement fractionné mensuel n'est qu'une
facilité de paiement la garantie étant
bien accordée sur l'année complète donc
il ne paraît pas en tous les cas là
aussi inconvenant en terme de respect
des droits et devoir de chacun
l'assureur quelle que soit la forme
mutualiste compagnie d'assurance
notamment et l'assurer dans un respect
des engagements parce que derrière vous
avez aussi des équilibres économiques et
je vous sais aussi attentif à ses
équilibres économiques donc je ne doute
pas monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur que après avoir dit non tout
à l'heure vous initier peut-être par
dire oui cette fois-ci merci avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
la suppression du droit de l'assurée au
remboursement du au Prat de sa prime si
ce dernier a d'or et déjà déclaré un
sinistre c'est l'objet de votre demande
il s'agirait là d'une réduction assez
importante de la liberté du choix de
l'assurée et donc nous j'y donnerai un
avis défavorable merci avis du
gouvernement même avis même avis je mets
donc au voit l'amendement de Monsieur
Husson 85 laquels sont ceux qui sont
pour son
adoption avis contraire il n'est pas
adopté amendement 182 rectifié madame
procassia
euh j'ai déjà dit en première lecture
tout le mal que je pensais de la
résiliation de la RC auto la RC auto
c'est quelque chose qui protège autrui
il y a vraiment déjà trop
d'automobilistes qui ne sont pas
couverts par la RC auto c'est le fond de
garantie auto en qui même sil a changé
un peu de N de noms qui couvre tous les
dommages qui peuvent être
qui peuvent être provoqué par des gens
qui ne sont pas assurés pour qu'en plus
permettre que la RC auto ne puisse être
euh qu'on puisse se résilier c rcuto
comme on le veut sans vérifier vraiment
si on a une nouvelle assurance puis
comme je l'ai dit la nouvelle assurance
c'est pas quand on l'a souscrit c'est
quand on a commencé à la payer parce que
quand vous avez souscrit une assurance
et le temps que vous receviez l'appel de
cotisation si vous payez pas vous êtes
encore couvert par pendant 3 mois je
sais pas monsieur hon me contredira ou
pas si c'est ce délai donc on peut très
bien souscrire un contrat ne pas payer
ne pas être couvert provoquer des
accidents et c'est les personnes les
tiers qui sont en cause en outre
pourquoi je redépose cet amendement pour
parce que je me suis posé une question
depuis quelques mois puisque ce n'est
que la RC auto que l'on peut résilier la
plupart du temps les RC auto elle est
compris dans une assurance auto est-ce
que ça va conduire les assureurs à
devoir maintenant
proposer une responsabilité civile qui
est sortie de la responsabilité globale
et dans ces cas-là imaginez l'assuré qui
va qui va décider de résider son RC auto
sans se rendre compte qu'il aura pas
résigner son assurance auto et bien
l'assuré il sera encore une nouvelle
fois
perdant merci avis de la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur la suppression de la
possibilité de résiliation infraannuelle
l'assurance responsabilité civile
automobile c'est l'objet de votre deè
demande donc avis défavorable à la
suppression d'une majeure de ce projet
de loi en matière de liberté de choix de
son assureur voilà AVF merci même avis
du gouvernement même avis je mets donc
au vo l'amendement de Madame procassia
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté amendement 170 il
est retiré et je mets donc au voix
l'article 21 quels sont ceux qui sont
pour adopter l'article
21 avis contraire il est adopté nous en
arrivons à l'article 21 B avec
l'amendement 289 rectifié de Madame
procaia de fixer un délai de mise en
vigueur de la loi puisque c'est pas du
jour au lendemain que l'on peut changer
tous les systèmes informatiques prévenir
l'ensemble des assurés même si un
certain nombre vont sans doute se lancer
dans des campagnes de pub pour avertir
les assurés donc cet amendement prévoit
que
l'article sera mis en vigueur 12 mois
après la promulgation de la loi rel du
du de la loi sur la
consommation merci avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur e les délis donc
c'est défavorable au consommateurs donc
avis défavorable merci même avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre même
avis je le mets au voix quels sont ceux
qui sont pour l'adoption du
289 avis contraire il n'est pas adopté
je mets au voie l'article 21 bis quel
ceux qui sont ceux qui souhaitent
adopter l'article 21 bis avis contraire
il est adopté et nous arrivons au 21 ter
avec l'amendement 124 rectifié qu'
monsieur
deoche ah pardon madame de
roche madame
bog parce qu'on a de roches aussi de
roches
Roch merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur monsieur le
ministre l'article 21 ter prévoit qu'en
cas de réparation d'un véhicule ayant
subi un dommage garanti par le contrat
l'assurer à la faculté de choisir
réparateur professionnel l'amendement
présenté a pour but de permettre à
l'assurée de convenir avec le réparateur
non agréé par son assureur qu'il aurait
choisi de bénéficier du règlement direct
en cédant au réparateur sa créance
constitué de l'indemnité
d'assurance merci quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur on est
dans un texte conso donc avis
défavorable merci avis du gouvernement
même avis merci je le mets au voix quels
sont ceux qui sont pour adopt
l'amendement 124 rectifié avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté 290 rectifié qui le
défend il est défendu avis de la
commission défavorable même avis du
gouvernement même avis même vote même
vote et je mets l'article 21 ter quels
sont ceux qui souhaitent adopter
l'article 21 ter avis contraire
il est adopté article 214 avec
l'amendement 87 de Monsieur Husson
87 et puis le 88 rectifié volontiers ben
c'est
de je on finira par obtenir gain C
j'espère monsieur le ministre parce que
voilà deux amendements qui vont
complètement dans le sens d'une
écriture plus simple plus claire en
faveur du droit de la consommation des
consommateurs des assurés qui ne laisse
pas les compagnies ni les mutuels vous
l'avez compris c'est à la fois de
pouvoir pour le 87
rectifié préciser que la forme format
papier ou le forme la forme
dématérialisée je dirais est accessible
aux assurés pour leur faciliter les
choses notamment également dans la
présentation pour le 87 rectifi
d'exemples précis sur toutes les
dépenses de 100
parce que dans les dépenses de santé on
est bien placé pour le savoir les ce
qu'on appelle les tarifs de
responsabilité ou les tarifs de
convention ne varient quasiment jamais
donc c'est simplement sur la part
variable de la part complémentaire que
les choses peuvent être exprimées elles
sont parfois exprimé en franc parfois
exprimé en pourcentage du remboursement
de la part complémentaire autant vous
dire qu'il vaut mieux donner des
explications parfaitement claires avec
des des exemples
illustrés et c'est un peu la même chose
pour le 88 rectifié donc allant dans le
sens de la formation la meilleure
information des assurés je vous
remercie merci quel est l'avis de la
commission sur ces deux amendements 87
88 l'amendement 87 va dans le sens de
l'allègement des contraintes imposées
aux assureurs mais il restraint
drastiquement les obligations
d'information à l'égard des
consommateurs et des assurés donc avis
défavorable et même esprit pour le 88
avis défavorable merci avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre oui
sur cet amendement le 97 et je crois le
le le 88 à suivre qui d'ailleurs vise un
objectif que l'on peut parfaitement
partager cependant considérons que
l'objet de l'amendement est déjà
satisfait par la terminologie que nous
avons proposé initialement en effet la
terminologie les supports commerciaux
dématérialisés ou à défaut sous forme de
papier et déjà visé dans l'expression
plus large j'ouvre les Guillet les
documents de communication à leurs
assurés ou destinés à faire leur
publicité les conditions de prise en
charge fermé la guillemet par ailleurs
le défaut principal de cet amendement
c'est qu'il conduit à modifier
uniquement le code des
assurancesésent article traite des
entreprises d'assurance des institutions
de prévoyance et des mutuelles union il
n'apparaît donc pas souhaitable de
différencier les acteurs du marché dans
sélectif c'est donc la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement donne à cet
amendement et au suivant un avis
défavorable comme le rapporteur merci je
vais donc mettre au voie ces de
amendements en commençant par le 87
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté même vote
sur le 88 même vote je mets au voix
l'article 21 quoiel quels sont ceux qui
sont pour son
adoption avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté il est
adopté pardonnez-moi article 22 B deux
amendements identique de suppression le
50 du président
mard monsieur le Président Monsieur le
mes chers collègues la présentation de
cet amendement si vous voulez bien sera
vaudra également pour les amendements 51
52 et 53 qui sont en fait des
amendements de
coordination la question du régistre
national des crédits au
particulier que nous appelons
communement fichier positif a été très
longuement débattu en première lecture
monsieur le ministre vous avez
développé avec brio comme d'habitude un
grand nombre
d'arguments pour nous convaincre de la
pertinence et de l'utilité du dispositif
que vous proposé aux articles 22 B et
suivant de ce projet de loi donc cet
amendement qui vise à supprimer ce
dispositif et surtout nous l'avons
compris un amendement d'appel une
occasion de rappeler les réticences et
les inqui étude de notre groupe à propos
de ce fichier
positif qui malgré vos efforts que nous
reconnaissons monsieur le ministre ne
sont pas toutes levées tout d'abord bien
que le dispositif proposé tente de tenir
compte des critiques formulées par le
Conseil d'État et laaknil quant à la
proportionnalité entre les données
contenu dans ce fichier son objectif
c'est-à-dire la lutte contre le
surendettement nous persistons à nous
interroger sur la compatibilité d'un tel
fichier avec le respect des libertés
individuelles et c'est c'est un débat
qui n'est pas nouveau qui d'ailleurs
était je dirais partagé dans nombre de
groupes en outre nous regrettons
l'absence d'étude d'impact sur ce
dispositif certes vous l'avez rappelé de
nombreuses études ont été réalisées sur
ce sujet mais nous aurions souhaité une
évaluation précise de l'efficacité
attendue du dispositif retenu par le
gouvernement en terme de lutte contre le
surendettement si ce régistre permet
effectivement un certain nombre de
ménages d'éviter le crédit de trop celui
qui met dans le trou les faisant
basculer dans le surendettement alors ce
sera une bonne chose mais les exemples
étrangers en particulier celui de la
Belgique ne sont guerre encourageants et
je rappelle que dans ce pays le nombre
de dossiers de surendissement a continué
d'augmenter malgré la mise en place d'un
tel fichier voilà une partie des raisons
qui ont conduit plusieurs membres de mon
groupe à douter de la nécessité et de
l'efficacité de ce régistre national les
crédits au particuliers créés par cet
article 22 bis et en proposer par voie
de conséquence la suppression merci le
212 madame Church
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues vous avez
rappelé dès la discussion générale
monsieur le ministre votre attachement
au registre national des crédits au
particulier nous partageons la volonté
qu'il av vaut d'indiquer le
surendettement cependant comme nous
l'avons dit en première lecture nous
pensons que le fichage systématique des
consommateurs détenteurs de certains
crédits ne constitue ni une réponse
humaine ni une solution efficace pour
les aider à faire face à leurs dépenses
ce premier point est essentiel nous
sommes farouchement opposé à ce procédé
qui aboutit à interdire l'accès au
crédit sans autre solution que de
renoncer à la dépense ou alors trouver
une substitution plus nocive sur un
marché parallèle en réalité une fois que
l'on aura refusé à une famille un crédit
que va-t-on lui proposer pour faire face
à ses dépenses comment vat-on l'aider
pour vivre décemment ensuite de notre
point de vue le dispositif que vous
proposez est à la fois trop large pour
respecter la vie privée de chacun au
regard notamment du principe de
proportionnalité est pas assez large
pour être réellement efficace comme nous
l' avion expliqué expliqué en première
lecture un tel fichage systématique de
plus de 10 millions de personnes fait
peser un risque dangereux sur la
protection des données personnelles et
difficilement acceptable au regard des
libertés publiques en effet depuis
septembre monsieur le ministre de
nombreux exemples ont montré combien
aucun fichier n'est termétique et
comment l'exploitation illicite des
données personnelles n'est pas une
hypothèse d'école les députés ont
supprimé l'inclusion des opérations de R
et de regroupement de crédit à la liste
des crédits devant être obligatoire ce
qui comme vous l'avez noté monsieur
fauconier risquait de fragiliter sa
conformité au principe de
proportionnalité en effet se poserit la
question de la réintégration dans le
périmètre du RNC d'une partie des
crédits immobiliers ce qui m'amène à à
évoquer le second point l'inefficacité
de la mesure à notre avis en effet selon
une étude du Crédit foncier sur le
marché européen des crédits immobiliers
les pardon les crédits immobiliers
représentent 87 % dans l'endettement
total des ménages en Europe fin 2012 les
13 % restants sont constitués de crédit
à la consommation en France le crédit
immobilier représente 85 % de
l'endettement total dès lors comment
penser que ce registre soit efficace
pour juger de l'endettement si on exclut
la principale cause d'endettement
justement ensuite vous avez dit monsieur
le ministre que ce registre responsab
responsabiliserait le prêteur on voit
pas pourquoi d'ailleurs se pose ici la
question du contrôle et de la sanction
des comportements abusifs des vendeurs
de crédit à ce titre nous aurions aimé
que nos propositions sur l'interdiction
des cartes confuse sur l'interdiction du
crédit renouvelable soit mieux prise en
compte dans ce projet de loi enfin
lutter contre le surendettement c'est
également conserver le réseau de
proximité de la Banque de France or le
plan Banque de France 2020 impose la
suppression de milliers d'emplois
sacrifie l'aide aux citoyens surendettés
et la présence de la Banque de France au
service des agents économiques des
Collectiv et des collectivités pour
toutes ces raisons qui me semblent quand
même des raisons que vous pourriez
entendre monsieur le ministre nous vous
demandons d'adopter la suppression de
cet article 22
bis merci quel est donc l'avis de la
commission monsieur le
rapporteur
on va je pense pas refaire le débat
qu'on a fait qui était passionnant mais
tout le monde la dans la tête en
souvenir en quelque sorte on a on a été
quelques-uns pendant des mois et des
mois à auditionner à essayer de trouver
un compromis c'était un travail qui a
été fait entre les différentes
commissions et à l'issue de de ce
travail
là à peu près chacun est resté un peu
sur ses positions mais tous tous tous je
le dis bien ont été quand même ébranlés
par un certain nom d'auditions le
ministre leur raeler Crésus le secro
catholique le secour populaire et donc
quand on entend ça même si on a
peut-être de façon légitime des on peut
imaginer qu'il peut y avoir quelques
risques euh on est quand même très très
ébranlé et ceux qui sont très favorables
ou défavorables même les défavorables
sortez ces auditions en se disant oui
peut-être et cetera hein donc moi je
fais partie de ce qui était favorable
totalement favorable depuis le début on
était quelques-uns et je suis encore
aujourd'hui convaincu que il faut mettre
en place ce fichier positif
euh tous les présidents successifs je
dis bien tous les présidents que ce soit
Shira que ce soit euh Sarkozi que ce
soit Hollande avait promis ce fichier ce
registre puisque dès qu'on parle de
fichier bien entendu tout le monde monte
aux arbres dans ce pays ce qui est ce
qui peut se comprendre hein
euh je crois que très
sincèrement qu'il est dans une
configuration puisque le ministère le
ministre a a essayé de reprendre ce
dossier qui avait été un peu retoqué
dans des consultations au niveau du
Conseil d'État si j'ai bien compris hein
il est pas ce que nous souhaitons les
favorable c'est évident on le sait très
il est pas que nous on le voudrait
beaucoup plus performant mais on sait
très bien
que si on il devient ce qu'on ce qu'on
aurait souhaité les favorables il ne
verra jamais le jour il ne verra jamais
le jour hein et là je vais pas de Procé
d'intention mais je vois bien qu'il a un
certain nombre d'amendements qui sont
des amendements sincères en disant moi
je veux le le projet tel que je le
souhaitais c'est-à-dire un projet un
projet de un registre efficace hein puis
d'autres se disent finalement le Renda
efficace ça va le plomber ça va faire en
sorte qu'il verra jamais le jour puisque
ce sera R ok donc voilà c'est un c'est
moi je crois que c'est pas l'outit qui
va tout résoudre mais je pense c'est un
bon outil et il permettra me semble-t-il
ce qui me semble ce qui a été
déterminant dans ma dans ma décision et
dans mon mon jugement c'est de faire en
sorte que quand il y a des procès on a
auditionné les les juges quand il y a
des
procès et que le banquier qui a qui a
casé ou le prêteur qui a casé 30 crédit
revolving puisse pas dire attendez moi
il me l'a pas dit cétait déclaratif moi
je savais pas et donc systématiquement
systématiquement le prêteur s'en sort et
c'est c'est la la victime c'est le
consommateur et on a tous dans nos
proximités des situations dramatiques
dramatiques alors elles auraient
peut-être pas elles auraient été
pareilles probablement mais moi je pense
que là on est dans une décision qui
appartient à chacun elle est pas c'est
respectable ce que vous avez dit les uns
les autres les autres mais je pense
qu'on a un choix personnel à faire et je
sais qu'il est partagé dans d'autres
bancs sur tous les bancs ici et vraiment
mettons en place ce fichier ce registre
faisons en sorte de le de le faire vivre
après de convaincre ce qui était
rétissant de de se prémunir contre les
excès ce que j'entends tout à fait mais
de grâce il y a me semble-t-il urgence
voilà je vous remercie donc moi avis
défavorable à ces deux amendements merci
monsieur le rapporteur avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre sans
surprise la gouvernement sera évidemment
défavorable à ces deux amendements de
suppression pour mémoire sur les
arguments sur les
libertés
national après première consultation
allit rendre un avis négatif sur au
motif qu'il était disproportionné parce
qu'il intégrait justement les crédits
immobiliers ça permet de vous dire
effectivement l'éte du crédit fonci qui
est juste mais elle juge les ménages
endettés pas surendettés la plupart des
ménages surendettés par bonheur pour
l'essentiel ne sont pas propriétaires
heureusement et quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui la structure des ménages
surendettés à la Banque de France on a
quand même travaillé l'essentiel des
crédits qui aujourd'hui caractérise le
surendettement des personnes
surendettées prises en charge par la
Banque de France ce sont des crédits à
la consommation sinon il y aurait pas
une telle offensive contre le crédit
renouvelable le le l'étude du Crédit
Foncier elle porte sur vous moi tous les
Français les surendettés mais tous les
ménages qui se sont endettés pour
acheter et cetera donc évidemment au
regard de ce qu'on empreunte pour
acheter une maison par rapport à ce
qu'on empreunte pour acheter un meuble
évidemment la place du crédit immobilier
est beaucoup plus importante et je vous
dis la population quiil faut regarder
c'est la population surendettée et pour
la population surendettée là on constate
qu'on est entre 6 à 8 crédits à la
consommation qui justifie ou explique ce
surendettement je reviens à ce que
disait le Conseil d'État il nous a dit
donc revoyez votre copie nous avons revu
notre notre copie et nous avons eu un
avis favorable du Conseil d'État de
l'acnil et de la
CNCDH trois avis favorables sur le fait
que ce fichier n'était pas attentatoire
aux liberté fondamental je vous le dis
parce que c'est quand même un argument
j'entends parler de l'acnil je vous
propose même si et et c'est une ça peut
être amendé ou alors oralement peut-être
cela peut-il suffire mais que dans
l'article nous prévoyons la mise en
place d'un comité de suivi je vous
propose même que la knil soit membre de
ce comité de suivi du registre national
des crédit au particulierers de façon à
apporter toute garantiese sur le le le
le fonctionnement le le bon respect de
l'usage l'utilisation de ce fichier au
regard des libertés fondamentales si ça
doit faire l'objet d'un amendement du
Gouvernement j'y suis près si cela si
vous cela suffit que je m'exprime ici en
disant nous demandrons à laaknil vous me
le dites mais en tout cas moi je suis je
je je m'y engage personnellement on nait
pas prévu de déposer on n pas déposé
encore d'amendement gouvernemental mais
si on peut le si on doit le faire moi
j'y suis prêt enfin bon le rapporteur a
tout dit moi je répète ce faut pas nous
faire dire ce qu'on ne veut pas dire le
registre national crédit au particulier
ne va pas tuer le surendettement en
France il va lutter contre le
malendettement détecter plus précocement
la réalité du surendettement et nous
permettre de de réagir plus vite parce
que je rappelle qu'à une personne
surendettée comme à la collectivité ça
coûte plus cher de désendetter quelqu'un
que d'éviter qu'il s'endette c'est aussi
une mesure de prévention qui justifie la
mobilisation des ONG et et je l'ai dit à
Madame chch la dernière il y a 2 jours
parmi les banques la banque qui s'est
illustrée il y en a deux mais une
mutualiste et l'autre banque qui s'est
illustrée en faveur du Registre national
de crédit au particulier et la seule
banque 100 % publique c'est la Banque
Postale donc il y a quand même à
regarder qui est favorable aujourd'hui
au registre national de crédit au
particulier or la Banque Postale a elle
la connaissance parfaite depu publics
qui sont des publics qui ont parfois par
forcément aussi facilement accès au
services bancaires que cela donc moi je
je je vous le dis je j'entends vos
arguments je pense qu'on y a répondu et
on y a répondu parce que cette affaire
elle est elle date pas d'hier elle date
d'avant avant avanttiè et on sait bien
que on a été long à mûir notre réflexion
y compris celui que vous avez devant
vous puisque quand moi je suis devenu
ministre de la consommation je n'étais
pas favorable à ce des crédit
particulierers intuitivement j'avais les
mêmes réactions que vous et ent
travaillant à l'ône des points de vue
des uns et des autres je me suis forgé
une conviction et cette conviction m'a
amené à vous faire cette proposition de
sur croi je le rappelle c'est un
engagement issu de la Conférence
nationale de lutte contre la pauvreté et
l'exclusion décision prise en lien avec
les organisations dans ce domaine là
donc moi je vous proposerai deux choses
bon évidemment avis défavorable à à à à
vos à vos amendements mais le cas
échéant je me retourne vers mes
collaborateurs au premier rang si nous
pouvions euh euh faire peut-être
préparer un amendement pour ajouter dans
l'alinéa 13 de l'article en question le
fait que dans le comité de suivi il y
ait la knil moi je je je si ça peut être
de nature à vous à rassurer euh les
parlementaires moi le gouvernement y est
prêt merci monsieur le rapporteur et
Monsieur Berry debas j'ajoute par
rapport à ce qu'a dit le le ministre que
à la demande de la de la Commission on a
avait également mis deux parlementaires
ce qui était pas dans la loi de
sénateurs donc également dans le comité
de pilotage on l'a fait rajouter
également voilà tuavis compris ce qu'
bien sûr je suis moi très favorable à ce
que la gnil soit soit dans le dispositif
c'est
évident merci Monsieur ber debas oui je
je voudrais dire que je je suis
défavorable à c de amendements mais
c'est pas parce qu'ils sont présentés
par par d'un côté monsieur bizard et par
l'autre notre collègue Meor je suis tout
à fait défavorable parce que comme l'a
dit notre collègue rapporteur nous avons
travaillé là-dessus en amont de ce
projet de loi et nous étions tous les
deux convaincu de mettre en place un
dispositif pour lutter contre
effectivement à la fois ce qui est un
fléo pour des gens qui sont qui n'ont
pas de moyens et qui peut entraîner des
conséquences terribles humaines
terribles nous avons autour de nous moi
j'ai autour de moi j'ai été interpellé
par des personnes qui ont été conduite
au suicide à travers le système qui est
mis en place alors j'ai bien compris
c'est pas on va pas mettre fin au
surendettement mais on va quand même
limiter des pratiques et je crois que
bon moi je suis tout à fait favorable à
ce dispositif c'est pour ça que je ne je
m'exprime pour dire que je ne peux pas
voter votre amentement et que je voterai
contre parce que je pense que on devrait
à travers ça faire un premier pas et
comme l'a dit de façon excellente
notrepp raorteur il suffit d'écouter et
dans les auditions ça a été vu euh à
travers cressus à travers le Secours
catholique à travers le Secours
populaire à travers tout simplement des
des associations locales de voir le je
dirais le tout ce que ce qu'entraîne euh
un destif qui n'est pas maîtrisé donc
c'est pour ça on a maintenant un fichier
qui nous permet d'avancer même si ce
n'est pas la panercé je crois que il
faut pas supprimer ce dispositif
très bien Monsieur Merci monsieur
l'abbé monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues en première
lecture j'étais intervenu pour vous dire
combien la situation était dramatique
d'une part mais combien il était
dramatique de devoir arriver à à ce type
de fichage comme comme solution euh pour
la position que j'ai à prendre au nom du
groupe écologiste j'ai provoqué au mon
groupe un débat et nous sommes
extrêmement
partagé sur ce sujet mais je crois que
le le tissu associatif est aussi partagé
et la société est également partagée
alors cette création d'un régistre pour
nous écologistes recours systématique à
des pratiques à des pratiques de fichage
ça ne nous va pas du tout évidemment
l'accentuation du contrôle social
évidemment également la création d'un
outil quelque peu malgré tout
disproportionné et inadapté face aux
causes profondes surendettement ceci est
important quelles sont les causes
profondes dans leur ensemble les
écologistes sont attentifs au respect
des des liberté intellectuelle mais
c'est pas intellectuelle oui individuel
également mais c'est pas un privilège de
chez nous je sais que que que vous
l'êtes également la stigmatisation des
personnes le jugement qui consiste à
dire aux pauvres vous faites n'importe
quoi vous achetez des biens que vous ne
pouvez pas vous offrir c'est votre faute
on l'entend trop souvent ce discours là
et la réalité du surendettement c'est
quoi sur les 220000 dossiers de sur de
surendettement déposés en 2012 15 à
20000 sont liés à un excès de crédit
type acheteur compulsif le reste sont
des accidents de la vie qui arrivent
hélas de plus en plus souvent et trop
souvent chômage séparation maladie et
très vite on ne peut plus faire face à
ces charges sans compter que les
surantetté sans crédit ça existe aussi
tout ceux qui ne peuvent plus faire face
à leurs échéances de loyers facture
d'énergie et cetera est-ce que ficher
ces personnes résoudra leurs problèmes
retrouveront-ils un emploi verront-ils
leur salaire augmenté leur loyer baissé
bien sûr que non je sais nous savons
monsieur le ministre que vous avez
entendu nos
réserves vous avez tenté de contenir
l'étendue du du fichier et réussi ne
visant que les prêts à la consommation
ceux de ces sociétés financières qui ne
s'embarrassent guère de connaître la
réelle solvabilité des personnes qui
martellent leur pub par leurs affiches 4
par 3 leur spot télé radio leur
démarchage téléphonique oubliant souvent
de préciser le coup réel de leur service
la réalité c'est aussi celle-là dans ce
projet de loi d'autres moyens sont
également développé pour contrecarrer
des ces pratiques désastreuses celle qui
liit trop étroitement les cartes de
crédit aux avantages de la fidélité
celle qui oublie de proposer des crédits
amortissables plutôt que des crédits
renouvelables des assurances ont été
prises également pour que le fichier ne
devienne pas un fichier de prospect
alors Monsieur le monsieur le ministre
j'ai entendu votre volonté de travail en
urgence là pour associer lail au comité
de suivi dans cette mesure malgré toutes
les réserves que j'ai donné parce que
j'ai une position personnelle à prendre
dans un groupe qui est partagé qui me
fait confiance par rapport à la position
monsieur le ministre je le dis je vous
fais confiance donc je ne voterai pas
les amendes de les amendements de
suppression malgré t mais tous ces tous
les arguments que j'ai développés on
vous fera confiance parce que c'est un
c'est un c'est un point clé de votre de
votre loi nous vous nous vous suivons
avec grande confiance mais en espérant
mais je sais que c'est partagé que l'on
travaille aussi sur les causes en amont
et et ces causes sont évidemment
sociétales et les uns et les autres on a
y travaillé pour améliorer la situation
améliorer les les solidarités améliorer
la justice sociale améliorer la justice
fiscale je vous remercie merci Monsieur
Dallier merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je ne voterai pas non plus ces
amendements de suppression car je suis
très favorable à la constitution de ce
fichier ou de ce registre
appelez-le comme vous voulez et je fais
partie de ceux qui auraiit souhaité
aller plus loin alors je m'empresse de
vous le dire monsieur le rapporteur ça
n'est pas du tout dans l'idée de plomber
le dispositif et pour qu'il soit retoqué
je pense effectivement que si l'on
souhaitait être véritablement efficace
il faudrait inclure les regroupements de
crédit et les crédits immobiliers c'est
ce que je proposerai au travers de deux
amendements on verra bien ce qu'il en ce
qu'il en reste mais il faut que l'on
soit efficace et j'ai du mal
effectivement à comprendre les arguments
de la de la cil sur ce sujet
franchement si vous utilisez votre votre
carte bleue on vérifie que votre compte
est créditeur avant de vous délivrer de
l'argent alors là qu'est-ce que c'est
une atteinte à la liberté d'avoir son
compte débiteur qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire il y a tellement de sujets auxquels
la cil doit s'intéresser et elle s'y
intéresse entre la géolocalisation les
écoutes téléphoniques les écoutes sur
Internet la NSA et tout le reste sur ce
sujet-là on est vraiment dans un autre
registre et je ne considère pas que
c'est protéger la liberté individuelle
que laisser quelqu'un s'endetter avec
les conséquences que cela aura derrière
et on le sait bien tous les élus locaux
qui reçoivent des particuliers le savent
on a parfois des gens qui viennent au
CCS et qui demandent des prêts gratuits
on en fait et on découvre alors
effectivement ces multitude de prêts et
il y a parfois des gens qui sont
propriétaires qui se trouvent dans ces
situations donc moi je suis très
favorable à à ce registre j'aurais
souhaité qu'on aille plus loin nous
verrons si nous pouvons le faire mais en
tous les cas je ne peux pas voter ces
amendements de
suppression merci Madame
lard merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
sans R les débats bien sûr euh je
souhaite rappeler quelle est la position
historique du groupe que je représente
aujourd'hui le groupe uduc puisque voilà
des années et des années que nous
déposons de façon régulière des
propositions de loi tant à l'Assemblée
qu'au Sénat et je me souviens lorsque je
suis arrivé ici j'étais la benjamine
j'étais toute jeune dans cette assemblée
en 2001 le premier texte donc vous voyez
on vieillit tous ça me m'arrache quand
même le cœur de dire ça mais malgré tout
donc ce que je voulais dire c'est qu'en
2001 Monsieur amont c'était déjà au cœur
de nos débats je me souviens de la loi
de sécurité financière elle a tourné
pendant des heures et des heures autour
de cette question et on ne savait pas
comment aborder et comment formaliser ce
que nous arrivons enfin à coucher sur le
papier autour d'un consensus monsieur le
ministre que vous avez su mener tant
dans votre travail au gouvernement que
ici sur les bancs de l'Assemblée comme
du Sénat au travail de travail de
consultation qui ont été menés par des
commissions tous les parlementaires
étaient associés de toutes les
sensibilités ce que je veux dire c'est
que on voit bien que ce sujet il est
sensible on voit bien qu'il a nécessité
à être bordé mais on sait aussi très
bien que si on n'a pas des outils
fiables fins qui nous permettent de
prévenir dans l'intérêt des personnes
fragile ces situations où quelquefois on
est amené à pousser la plelotte faute
d'autres solutions et accompagner ces
familles parce que je suis sûr qu'il y a
des mesures de prévention et
d'accompagnement des familles à prendre
lorsqueeffectivement il y a plus de
solution il y a peut peut-être vers des
administrations des d'autres
alternatives qu'un crédit avec un taux
d'intérêt qui mettra encore plus en
fragilité ses familles mais donc si je
me permets d'intervenir c'est parce que
vraiment je crois que c'est l'intérêt de
nos familles l'intérêt général des
consommateurs et de nos population qui
est visé au travers de ce cette
disposition que les uns et les autres
nous avons essayé de sécuriser
d'équilibrer personnellement je ne
redéposerai pas tout en partageant
l'avis de philippe Dallier un amendement
sur les crédits immobiliers parce que
j'ai aussi entendu qu'il fallait
procéder par ordre et installer ce
fichier positif progressivement en
touchant dans un premier temps que les
crédits à la consommation par contre je
pense que les rachats de crédit parce
que c'est un rassemblement de crédit
existant et que ça donne une
photographie précise de la situation des
crédits à la consommation des familles
quelquel je pense vraiment que on peut
avec cette réalité bien sécurisé avec le
partenariat et les commissions qui vont
être créées pour faire en sorte tout le
monde soit bien consulté tout au long de
sa mise en œuvre et bien vraiment je
crois qu'on fera un grand pas c'est vrai
on va pas supprimer tous les problèmes
du jour au lendemain la fragilité
financière des familles les difficultés
seront toujours là mais si on peut les
prévenir prendre les difficultés à la
racine accompagner ces personnes et bien
on aura franchi un pas énorme au service
de l'intérêt général c'est pourquoi je
voterai contre cet amendement parce
qu'il me semble vraiment aller encore
une fois dans l'intérêt des personnes
fragiles
merci notre toujours jeune collègue
monsieur
Donis oui je serai extrêmement bref
parce que beaucoup de choses ont été
dites et il est pas inutile il est pas
utile de de revenir sur beaucoup
d'arguments qui ont été été échangés
juste un point personnellement je
n'accepterai jamais que il puisse y
avoir au nom d'une non stigmatisation
des pauvres une sorte de laisser faire
laisser aller qui puisse être octroyé
pour une raison très
simple cela
part d'une d'un postulat comme quoi
n'importe qui d'entre nous pourrait
subir sans dommage les accidents de la
vie et parfois la violence liée à ces
accidents de la vie quand on personnes
qui du jour au lendemain on des
décisions diverses voi leur vie ul qui
d'entre nous peut dire qu'il resterait
dans une sérénité complète qu'il ne
pourrait pas être soumis à telle ou
telle pression ne serait-ce qu'à un
moment donné le regard de tel ou tel
conjoint enfant qui fasse qu'il il ne
savou même plus à lui-même la réalité la
violence de la situation qu'il subit et
il a besoin d'accompagnement en tant que
maire je le constate tous les les jours
y compris parfois dans certaines classes
couches sociales qui sont pas forcément
les plus défavorisé et qui se retrouvent
confronté à des
situations regard social le regard
affectif bref un ensemble fait que il
n'y arrive plus et cet accompagnement ce
travail de prévention nous ne pouvons
pas le faire si nous n'avons pas un
certain nombre d'outils C ce répertoire
pe le terme de fich
peut choqué mais il y en a pas d'autres
hein en l'occurrence c'est un fichier
assumons-le en tant que tel bien et bien
cela va être un outil qui nous est
nécessaire parfois les prê les personnes
qui qui
s'adressent au Centre Communal d'Action
Sociale concerern des sommes très
modiques mais qui additionner les unes
aux autres dans beaucoup de cas et bien
constitue après des somme
importante c'est pour ça que je suis je
rejoins les différents collègues qui ne
peuvent pas voter un tel amendement de
suppression merci Monsieur
Mirassou merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
et oui bien sûr que ce n'est pas
satisfaisant de se dire que en Extrême
Limite et bien on est obligé d'avoir
recours à ce type de moyens donc ce
fameux fichier mais pour autant puisque
c'est le seul moyen efficace qui est à
la portée de notre main l'urgence de la
situation nous incite effectivement à
avoir recours et à faire en sorte que
l'utilisation se fasse par la suite avec
discernement moi je rejoins complètement
l'intervention de Joel Labé tout à
l'heure qui consiste à décortiquer les
raisons de multiples endettements et
donc faire aussi œuvre de pédagogie pour
que face à une agivité croissante en
terme de citation à l'achat il est au
bout du bout ça demandera du temps un
comportement qui soit plus citoyen
notamment par rapport aux familles qui
sont sur le plan économique les les plus
vulnérables et j'ai la conviction du
reste monsieur le ministre que le texte
que vous nous présentez aujourd'hui est
un texte qui globalement s'inscrit dans
cette mission qui consiste à faire en
sorte que et bien cette approche plus
citoyenne est plus vertueuse à la limite
puisse voir un jour le jour donc c'est
sans aucune ambiguïté qu'en ce qui me
concerne conscient que dans l'absolu la
situation n'est pas satisfaisante mais
que ça nous quittons l'hémicycle du
Sénat mais nous allons revenir bien
entendu plus largement sur la question